Booya so what were you saying about
tranch lo Hawkes tarantula hawk wasps
yeah they're big [ __ ] that main resent
me so this is one of the there's a guy
who made a scale right and he got stung
by all the different insects and this is
if I think five there's also a five plus
they're very hard to get you to sting
them there's a guy who online goes
through and gets the most done but the
reason they're so dangerous or so
venomous what they do is they sting the
tarantula lay their eggs inside the
tarantula and then tarantulas eaten
alive by the offspring for hour weeks
right and then when this was discovered
this kind of stuff in the Middle Ages
they were like this is a big theological
dilemma because God why would God make
this happen yeah why would God do that
nature is I mean I could go down this
rabbit hole
for hours please do yeah I mean seen
that gigantic flower that they found
it's not Alicia [ __ ] so one of the one
of the cousins to that flower is called
something in fantasy de so the insane
thing about that flower roughly it's the
largest flower in the world it only
lasts two weeks yeah but the plant
Harris all right so the plant that it
comes from has no stems roots or leaves
so you can't keep it on display because
it is entirely inside another species of
vine yeah it's completely parasitic
right yes it's there that's [ __ ] huge
look at that thing
yeah and they smell they smell gonna
call corpse flowers cuz they smell like
a rotting flesh too weird and they don't
know why it's so big just to trap rats
it's automatic no it does it's it's not
carnivorous it's the flower get sneaky
yes people look how big they are they're
gorgeous they are beautiful oh wow look
at that one where the guy's got his hand
on it before it yes so that's what it
looks like sitting on the ground and
then it pops open
that's some [ __ ] Avatar [ __ ] right so
I have something from the island of
Socotra which is an archipelago near the
coast of Yemen called Duval Diandra duv
al I and D are a and their flowers look
and smell like meat whoa because you
want to attract flies and the hotter it
gets in the house the more the flower
smells
it's really cool when you get it to
someone actually heat activated just
like rotten food would be yeah the trick
the flies because flies are gonna be
attracted there it is
they're number seven right there Jim you
see them this is the second the third
one on the left there that's it
you can look at the texture Wow and it
even has hairs to replicate a wound oh
it looks like a blown out bottle yeah
but from an alien oh there is a little
little dot in there oh there is a
butthole that smells like [ __ ] if you
look up Whites ellonija white SLO a an
da it smells like an [ __ ] and has
hairs that wriggle in the wind oh and
it's it to replicate an [ __ ] to a WH
ite SL o EI and ei White's ellonija
named after white and Sloan this from
Somalia oh yeah look at those flowers Oh
God
how weird just the sheer variety and
that smells like a butthole and has hair
on it yeah and the hair moves my friend
calls it God's mistakes but with the
sheer variety of nature so weird isn't
it great I mean we're just
I mean that's not unusual if an [ __ ]
is not unusual and every animal has an
ass well why is it unusual to have a
plant that looks like an [ __ ] and we
have the expression you attract more
flies with honey than Vera but it smells
like like a pig - [ __ ] a fly - [ __ ]
you're gonna have flowers that smell
like [ __ ] yes and there's a lot of them
there's a whole family of them and
they're gorgeous
yeah they smell and when they pop open
they fart it's like a fart cuz it's
contained and then it pops open oh so
like the gas has come out of it when it
pops over yeah it releases a dose yeah
look ups the biggest one stop Aaliyah
sta PE Li a are there any plants that
have the same effect on people that like
you know that one well not it's not a
plan actually is a fungus so there's one
branch of the cordyceps mushroom that
infects ants and gets up makes them
insane yeah so that they spray the
spores everywhere they die it grows
inside of them then literally explodes
out into the air so this spores will
infect other ants well when ants find
out that one of their members has been
in fact
they'll take that ant way out of the
community like wait they'll take him on
a walk yeah because they know somehow or
another that this thing's gonna blow up
on all their family they took they hat
down footage of this and literally like
the mushroom grows out of the ants head
and yeah ops out yeah it's there's a lot
of things that they're learning now
about nature controlling the minds of
other beings which is really a recent
con discovery and Locke's news Fox News
am i right that's more like faux news am
i right yeah that that sort of parasitic
relationship we one of my favorite ones
ever was the the grasshopper that gets
infected by this aquatic worm the
aquatic worm gets it to commit suicide
so that it can give birth to this worm
it literally gets into the wiring of the
grasshoppers brain and convinces it to
jump into a puddle what about the louse
that eats fish's tongues and then
becomes a functional tongue and becomes
the tongue yeah
farc so there's there's a lot of this
kind of crazy stuff i my understanding
is the majority of species actually
parasitic really yeah there's because
it's so much easier to be a parasite you
latch on you're getting nutrition you
don't got to do anything you know the
hunt
you have to graze and you're just set
well that's also just obviously
parasitic if you want to think about it
most organisms are semi Parekh and that
we need other organisms in order to
survive
you know like if you're a farmer I don't
want to say you're a parasite if you're
a beef farmer there's a headline the
farmers are parasites Joe Rogan 2020 is
gonna be living off that organism well
yeah and but the other thing is if every
species has several parasites think how
many we have license oh yeah rights it
makes sense that the majority gonna be
parasitic even if the micro-level you
get down to our gut oh yeah all the
different bacteria that's on your skin
we're filled with stuff yeah it's it's
really fascinating how clever many of
these organisms are yeah it's a trip
it's a weird thing to be a person my
friend I wouldn't no kidding yeah yeah I
agree it's it's but it's just all so
weird how we're finding out things that
are even crazy
here and crazier like right now they're
doing a lot of deep-sea exploration and
the things at the bottom of the ocean
are just like what is this you saw that
deep stariha thing mm-hmm the jellyfish
that looks like a lava lamp yes so it's
just like what it is pull up that
[ __ ] butt yeah deep stariha yeah
there's that's it that's one of the more
amazing things about the bottom of the
ocean right is a bioluminescence we saw
yeah
these creatures that I have a light
source thank you well there's also
dragon fish use a red light source
because red doesn't show off show up for
others so they can see what they but no
one else can it's like my vision oh yeah
this is the one crazy
you saw this yeah this is just amazing
oh it's so cool and this so pretty
what's amazing is how they're freaking
out the scientists are watching it
they're like what is going on
oh I love this thing and it's also has a
parasite on it or a symbiotic
relationship there's a copepod living
inside a resident isopod yes yeah [ __ ]
look how pretty that is now this thing
has never seen light from millions of
years it's the bottom of the sea so the
fact that it knows how to react to so or
is having a reaction is a pretty cool
just the fact that that's a real thing
that exists if we found that on the
planet somewhere would freak out this is
the Overlord this is the Overmind of the
planet and it's in a gelatinous form and
it communicates to you with vibrations
this is why my autism wouldn't let me
watch Star Trek as a kid because I knew
about all this stuff and then I'm
watching Star Trek and they're going to
another planet it's like a guy with the
blue face and I'm just like this is
stupid it's just a guy it's just the guy
whereas look at Earth look at this right
look at an octopus yeah look at that
you've seen the video of the octopus
taking out the seagull oh yeah what
about the blanket octopus it's
interesting those they saved an eagle an
octopus took out an eagle invent oh yes
an eagle and the fisherman pulled it
ashore and remove the octopus from the
noble Eagle but a seagull they were like
if sorry [ __ ] that's rap well they're
nasty they're thieves
well they are thieves both intono and
they smell eagles are thieves too we're
talking about a company that has raised
organic chickens that lost
2.2 million dollars in chickens to
eagles they they kill 160,000 Eagles
excuse me the Eagles killed 160,000 oh
yeah yeah okay so here it is the octopus
come bald eagle
what is that I hate America well he
doesn't he's in Canada huh
bald eagles live in Canada - they're
expats they go over there to party and
have sex with underage Eagles they were
draft actors yeah for sure
oh there's no rules up there that wild
land to the north but look at that they
decided to save the [ __ ] thing and
that weird oh my god Wow
if you're gonna save it I think you
should eat the octopus too because you
win yeah Carissa that octopus could have
been as large as 4.5 feet good everybody
gets to eat yeah that's that's automatic
go don't let it go there's plenty of
them things Jack that [ __ ] get lunch
it's only got a year long lifespan
anyway does it oh yeah you know the
octopus life cycle that big Yahoo lives
a year yeah definitely yeah zero remorse
zero [ __ ] I would have been zero in
Morrisville if I found it only lived a
year yeah like look at him he's gotta be
11 I have and they don't really feel
pain they can cannibalize themselves
they let their arms go when the female
octopus tries to eat them yeah yeah
female octopuses this is one of my
favorite parts about the the animal
kingdom they pretend sometimes that they
won't have sex the male octopus then
they just Jack I'm gonna eat him what
about the cuttlefish where they pretend
to be female so they yeah late yeah
they're like beta males that are male
feminists yeah they pretend to be
something that a female they pretend to
be phim and then they [ __ ] the females
have a it's not a male mannerisms and
characteristics just like these beta
males and they sneak up next to him as
an ally it's like they get their rocks
off it's like every Washington Post
reporter in the mollusk form you said
that well you're the one who said that
farmers are parasites but you do have
you have an excuse because you claimed
autism that's why you should listen to
me about climate change okay you're
already fun right I was saying that
earlier first podcast that a friend of
mine who actually used to work with
autistic kids thinks that girl is
autistic
she is autistic she says it it's on her
Twitter bio oh well there you go
yeah I didn't know that's how little I'm
paying attention to the news these days
yeah yeah I'm so happy so we should
definitely listen to the 16 year old
college high school dropout about
science so she is autistic it says that
on her it says I am autistic yeah
Asperger's
which is not a diagnosis anymore I am
autistic plus how dare you yeah
seven-year-old climate change
environmental activists with Asperger's
Oh was that always there with Asperger's
yes really so my most successful tweet
ever was I said there's my tweets how
many excuse me how many it follows was
chef Jimmy only see what four million oh
yeah yeah those are icky numbers you
gotta go on fed up my biggest ever tweet
I said there's no one more privileged
than the girl who refuses to go to
school until everyone on earth changes
the weather for her and then and I'm
like okay here's the rule weather is
when it contradicts your [ __ ]
climate is when it supports your
[ __ ] it's all rather its climate
okay go back to that first video that's
on her page the pinned video see if
their key play that only here was just
to say okay super important Fridays for
future the school strike continues this
is in September she was striking for
school we urge everyone to do the same
wherever you are
sit outside your Parliament's or local
government building until your nation is
on the safe path way okay suppose it
she's got beautiful for us does she I
like it
nice music behind it I'll do that's
soothing I feel like we're all gonna
work together and stop this thing it's a
very brave new world what we better stop
this thing because the climate oh let's
stop the planet first of all they are
the the the Nazis are lighting the
rainforest on fire so they can make more
cows and you need to go vegan Australia
yes
Australia do you know um Tim Poole
tweeted a statistic about the Australia
fires see if you can find it was it was
five hundred million animals yeah that's
one horrific statistic but his statistic
was I believe on the number of people
I'm pretty sure Tim Poole I might be
wrong now I'm second-guessing myself the
number of people that actually
intentionally set those fires
Wow yeah that there's not just one fire
there's many many many many fires and
there's not just accidental fires there
are fires that were set on purpose and
not a small amount of them like a
significant percentage of these fires
were
intentionally what to just clear ground
[ __ ] oh okay that's litters pickable
yeah literally [ __ ] that probably
never knew that it could get this crazy
a big problem with that is Australia
there's many species that are they live
there there are endemic there and
Australia won't let them be exported so
you don't have breeding colonies of a
platypus or echidna everywhere else so
when something like this happens it's
really disproportionately bad yeah they
were saying that koala bears are
functionally extinct because then we
know but then we google that and they
were refuting that right weren't they
Jamie well they're having this cancer
which is contagious and they're pissing
themselves to the bone like it's really
really bad yeah and I don't say cancer
yeah I don't stand out cancer could be
contagious but it's spreading really
yeah I read about that on or I listened
to that rather on a radio Lab podcast
yes the only form of cancer that they
had ever recorded that was contagious
makes no sense so crazy and all they eat
is eucalyptus trees right oh yes one
kind of leaf and they also have the
smallest brain-to-body proportion of any
animal they don't know why they're
violent when you [ __ ] them oh yeah
violent you try to [ __ ] them I've never
tried to [ __ ] a girl but no they are
they nasty no they they're well they're
wild animals and their brutal during the
mating process right like a lot of kids
have been like severely traumatized
watching koala bears rape other koala
bears like oh no pandas apparently too
well also cats so kids always raping
slices but he slices are up with the
barbs instead they make noises that you
like what in the [ __ ] is happening
outside my bedroom door she's being
raped with a knife oh yeah cuts are open
yes biting her neck yeah
like sharks and they go to war sometimes
- they [ __ ] fight and claw each other
and [ __ ] well then they also killed the
kids so that she'd get her period again
hats do that - yeah lions all felines I
didn't know kitty cats do that they have
that gland on the roof of the mouth -
male so they'll make that face and then
they're smelling if it's their kids
oh that they're doing that with their
mouths yes they can smell if it's their
own kids yes that is [ __ ] bonkers but
that's just amazing that like okay do I
have to kill these
children so I can rape their mom you
know who else does that it all funds
dolphins dolphin do what they killed the
Contra side yeah really I know that's
that's why female dolphins are severely
promiscuous because getting killed
because they [ __ ] everybody then you're
not gonna kill our kids cuz you know
whose kids they are right you don't have
Maury Povich in the ocean no it's just
all guesswork with dolphins this is like
damn I have been [ __ ] her a lot I has
a cute kid Leslie leave that kid alone
cuz when a female dolphin has birth
apparently she's not willing to mate
until her baby is viable or chance until
it's independent and I think that takes
like six years so they don't [ __ ] for
six years and the doll the male dolphins
life [ __ ] that you don't like they and
that kill the baby aren't they the only
other group that mates for pleasure or
has sex or pleasure no for short champs
yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't know what
other animals do it how many I would
want to go with that how many different
animals mate for pleasure I think it's
bonobos and maybe dolphins dolphins
definitely seem to do it humans
I hear do it I don't I don't understand
why they wouldn't want to mate for
pleasure because then you're getting
laid more I guess you don't want to get
laid too much and then you can't carry
the kids Yeah right and then there's not
enough resources I mean I think that
when you think about things like dear it
happened me there's a reason why they
only [ __ ] once a year and they're so
goddamn many of them a magic deer [ __ ]
every day be a plague pleasure pleasure
pigs okay
look at those look at those chimps
[ __ ] that's crazy they're doing it
missionary style huh and they look at
each other in the eye and he's like I'm
gonna give you just good that could be
rape I think that's the guy on the
bottom if I'm not is that right yeah I
look at the guy on the bottom it's a
[ __ ]
I think it's a guy yes it's a guy on top
so how many animals is this a few
minutes guess them all bonobos dolphins
and one or two species of primates
oh so it's only primates yeah we guessed
them so it's only animal but pigs pigs
yeah hmm please our smartest [ __ ] man
that's true there they're also
responsible for the most farm deaths is
that true yep how sell like charging
people
no they eat people people fall in no
pigs eat them oh yeah
didn't you ever see snatched what's now
I don't even know if that is Brad Pitt
you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] man well this
started on my Ritchie movie snatch you
don't know snatched I can't have a piece
of [ __ ] snatch yeah it's not snatch
that's my apologies that's a porn parody
snatched it's basically the same
storyline
well I'd be able to follow it if I
haven't watched snatch but they got
there's a gangster a really great
character in the movie snatch there's
this British guy with his giant coke
bottle glasses who's a [ __ ] murderer
and he talks about pigs about how you
could get rid of bodies with pigs so
they did that in the Hannibal movie yes
yes apparently it's it's all because of
well there's a reality to it but also
because there was a serial killer that
lived in British Columbia that guy he's
[ __ ] great brick top was his name and
I love his glasses oh my god
you never can we play a segment of that
no we can't we'll get pulled oh um too
bad but the guy is Fanta what is the
guy's name that actor he's [ __ ]
fantastic like he's not an actor like
while he's doing it you like that guy's
a gangster and he's really killing
people he's really feeding him
what is he Alan Ford that guy is a
[ __ ] beast he sent a lot of things
dude he's so good in that movie though
he's still so good as that evil gangster
I mean you buy it hook line and sink
it's a great movie okay I've seen that
movie I know
do I love Guy Ritchie movies I love
those English gangster movies like Lock
Stock and Two Smoking Barrels yeah I
love those movies got anyone on the way
to see it what Cooke called the
gentleman with Matt's nakaya's like a
millionaire weed dealer in London or
some [ __ ] yes seems like it's just right
out like this yes beautiful
I'm excited I love his movies okay I'm
not a big movie guy
what do you do for fun count numbers and
check ok we're gonna break this down
what means you're talking about being
artistic like sit around like number
people [ __ ] Rain Man [ __ ] right he
doesn't the count oh he does oh that's
the opposite he sees the toothpicks and
he knows how many there are you gotta
count
no that's the boy if you get the
instantaneous raise nonsense no two cans
it's like some superhero parcel bottles
did you do do you file superhero movies
or TV shows you seem like you would I am
an offense and there's a comic book
written about me so I am ago you know
this I did Harvey Pekar from American
Splendor he wrote a graphic novel oh
that's right we did talk about yeah yeah
so I am a comic actor I like other comic
books though yeah I was a huge comic fan
for a long time and I was just went to
some cool comic stores here in LA
there's some great ones like that indie
stuff the problem is a lot of its really
pretty but the writing is crap oh and
then you're really gonna face isn't it's
hard to get both it's hard to get both
yeah dude is your comic books an indie
comic books where there's like one guy
writes it and draws it yeah that's the
point they all it's always that case
right but then you don't want the artist
you know drawing it and then it gets
like are there anybody who does that
well where they draw it and write the
stories and do it well yeah Adrian
tahminae does it better than anyone is
it a girl or guy Dan wannabe or piece of
[ __ ] that ship has sailed
yeah but Adrian is I mean I know both
sides you know guys and girls
it's called optic nerve Dan Clowes is
amazing I'm blanking out their names but
there's a lot of real real talents yes
it's a very hipster mmm it's good in the
best way good writing good drawing there
yeah very emo um I don't see any
superheroes bro kind of comic is this
does anybody have magic or zero dragon
involved or an Elise and alien what this
is just an emo everyone's Brian get this
off the screen what does he say to stop
crying
magic word does he change from being a
crybaby to real man did you watch the
watch man No did you see the Watchmen
didn't Alan more like denounce it very
vociferously why did he do that I don't
know I watched one he's a difficult
reinvent I was like damn dr. Manhattan
looks like a normal person no he's got
to look like a god yes
he's got to be jacked yeah there was a
dr. Manhattan is supposed to be [ __ ]
jacked the guy to rock you
the guy who played him in the movie got
run over and killed
he hates the fitness sector yeah yeah
that guy he's dead no yes how old was he
when he died thirty thirty two teen year
old ran him over just like a train or
something I remember what it was yeah
see that so he was a fitness guy yeah it
was Greg Plitt that was his name let me
see a picture of that again and get my
pants off that's uh see that's what dr.
Manhattan's supposed to look like he's
supposed to look ridiculous like a super
person cuz he's a god yes he's got on
earth yeah yeah and he's glowing and
blue but now go to the new dr. Manhattan
the new dr. Manhattan was like hey
you're the guy who maybe does CrossFit
burger see look at his body I mean it's
okay he's definitely in good shape I'll
give you his playing a boxer you'd be in
it hook line and sinker yeah
but as dr. Manhattan like I know that's
not he's not doesn't look inhuman my
friend was like yeah and they also made
him a black guy I go duties blue he so
what the [ __ ] wrong with you
weren't they complaining about what Will
Smith being the genie for somebody yes
people complain about everything
although I do have to tell you I want to
see frozen the musical because I have
daughters so what you see frozen first
of all it was at the Pantages it's a
wonderful production it's excellent it's
really good I mean I actually enjoyed
the the musical it's very good however
it's about people that live in the
Arctic or they live in the Nordic
country right right that's what supposed
to be about there are all these blond
people white people well the dad's black
in the musical and the mom's Chinese
yeah okay and then the dad's black and
the moms Chinese which is great they're
great actors and dollars well then they
have kids in the kid one of the kids is
Chinese and one of the kids is white and
then the kids grow up and they're both
white Chinese girl becomes white and
there's no explanation given at all the
Chinese girls little she's Chinese or I
should say Chinese I'm a piece of [ __ ]
and there's a terrible thing to say I
meant to say a shot Evette [ __ ] no
she's a little girl
a [ __ ] girl she was he I don't know
if she's Chinese she was a young asian
girl did she became
a white girl did she make peepee in your
coke that's how you know she was great
at her job I mean she had perfect
singing and everything was beautiful
they're very talented but they're
requiring you to make this leap like now
you have to know that this is now a
different ethnicity yeah this is a
different person well not just a
different person but you can't even
pretend that's the same person like in
most movies where you have someone plays
a young version of the guy it looks like
the guy it's not like you have a young
Chinese guy who becomes Clint Eastwood
like hey what are we doing here like
what do we make you if you have a young
Clint Eastwood he's supposed to look
like who could be a young Clint Eastwood
they were even I talked about this in my
last book than you're right they were
even complaining there was a video game
that takes place in the Middle Ages very
popular maybe you guys know the name is
I'm blanking on it and they were
complaining that there weren't enough
black people there because everyone on
Twitter and Facebook still thinks
they're in the 60s and this is their
personal March on Salman they're
fighting against segregation and like
this isn't segregation this is history
yeah you can't if you want to watch make
a movie about Egypt right you should use
people that look like you're Egyptian
yes if you just decide you're gonna just
have only white people from Norway play
Egyptians people gonna want to kick your
ass and that's kind of the same thing
you're [ __ ] with reality
I'm not saying with frozen but with a
movie like or any historical depiction
anything where you're like depicting an
actual time you know if you want to have
like like the Wild West gonna do a movie
about the Wild West you have to have
European settlers you have to have some
African slaves sure and you have to have
a lot of a lot of Native Americans you
can't just decide we're gonna do a film
about the Wild West but everyone's black
black Cowboys are black all black crew
all black riders black power we're gonna
make it happen but you can't if you did
that movie people like wait are their
slaves yes okay so the black people have
slaves yes my favorite comic book series
of all time was Legion of super-heroes
right and I just place in the 30th
century and I was just thirty century
thousand years from now I was just in
the comic book store they just keep
rebooting it number two just came out
and I was looking at the cover
you have chameleon boy who's orange with
antenna
Brainiac 5 who's Green and a living
computer shadow lass is blue but they
had to make Lightning Lad black for some
reason now it's just like these are 40
diverse aliens some of them don't even
have a body but they have to change the
race just to it's just really kind of a
I guess the thing you do and stay woke
but in retrospect it's gonna be
embarrassing cuz you not know about
staying well I I'm very familiar do you
stay woke at all i I never sleep do you
ever think about like trying to be like
a little more woke and people like you
better never think of that no I don't
think they would like me better I think
you might if you might maybe give it a
little bit how can you like me better
it's already at 11:00 I'm the pride of
America this battles not going up it's
such a strange time man but it's always
a strange time I think now what makes it
good is that this can be called out and
discussed and be like look this isn't
about race or races and why is it
important to you yeah that's this
Chinese girl and frozen grows up to
become white like just explain this to
me I should say they did a great job
like everybody was awesome wasn't does
not in any way [ __ ] I enjoyed it it
didn't take away from my enjoyment it
was a very good music it did take away
because they're just like enjoy it more
enjoy it more because I saw the provoke
'no stop provoking I saw they did some
work [ __ ] I was like I see what you're
doing not to say that the Asian lady
wasn't fantastic as the mom she was the
the black eyes the dad he was amazing
but you want me to believe that a black
eye I made it with an Asian lady they
made two blonde kids and one of them
started out Asian and then became
European later we don't know that we
don't know that he was their dad yes we
do it's part of the script but they say
go describe their parents they have
children yeah my children grow you don't
know she's holding around no she's not
holding around because if she is she's
hoeing around with a goddamn chameleon
because the child morphs as it gets
older about a different race it changed
races of the same person the same
character yeah but the point is it's
still not gonna happen that a black guy
and a Chinese person are gonna have a
white kid so maybe the Chinese lady had
sex the white guy could be could be
could be he's a kook yeah it could be
frozen refers to the sperm that was
unfrozen good point
it's just amazing a Disney is people
think Corporate America is very
conservative but
the first ones to be pushing this stuff
I remember I was in Times Square in New
York Pride Month rainbow flags
everywhere and I said only corporate
America can make sodomy and perversion
look boring oh you son of a-- am i wrong
though your son of a [ __ ] yeah you know
in a way yeah how am I wrong no you're
right okay no I'm saying no it's a am i
wrong young definitely wrong no it's uh
yeah it's look do you remember when they
had that 11 year old drag queen oh the
Desmond is amazing yeah yeah yeah and
they were making this big deal about it
yeah and he's going to drag clubs and
dancing around they put it in the news
like it was some this what uh what a
great thing what a great thing he's
living his truth he's so brave he
imagine if there was a 12 year old that
was just sworn to be a ho like I am oh
I'm just gonna wear fishnets right and
high heels and I'm gonna stick my ass
out and I'm a dancer powder round with a
lot of makeup on how different is that
well he's also on the spectrum I think
I'm 99% sure so the and this photos him
videos with naked drag queens violet
chachki and it's just like look this is
something for well if there's like a
little boy who's being a Chippendales
you know what I mean it's like how is
this appropriate for kids and and it's
on Good Morning America it's different
they're a bunch of lady screaming and
trying to get that dick well I mean that
would be the equivalent right because
he's performing a gay clubs and they're
cheering a mom that's a place where
guide go to hook up with guys well
here's the question - do you think guys
have hooked up with him no oh god no oh
let's talk you want to talk about this
because this is a rabbit hole that I've
been on recently oh boy you know kids
getting [ __ ] Robert yeah because I had
a friend in October who sat me down and
he's like look I was raped as a kid for
a long time and he only realized because
of this show because he was watching
when Jake the snake was on the show oh
my my friend Matt and everything Jake
was saying he's like holy [ __ ] this is
me and this really [ __ ] him up for a
while and as he's talking to me and he
goes I can't even be mad because it was
another older kid and I know he was
getting it worse than me oh and the
thing that's really [ __ ] up is he
didn't know how I was gonna react
right so used to be mommy's sleepy no
mommy was a drunk right and until Betty
Ford the first lady came out as an
alcoholic now people like you be someone
says oh my mom is an alcoholic you're
like oh that sucks but you don't think
anything of him right if someone's if
daddy had a temper no daddy was abusive
but we know what to do with that
information and when I started talking
about this on Twitter and elsewhere that
this is really common and because all of
us do not think of kids in this way we
don't want to think about it's so sick
they're the ones who have to deal with
this nightmare and it's really really
everyone I've talked to know someone hmm
and I just told another friend when he's
like oh yeah my sister I just found out
was being molested by her grant our
grandfather their whole life and then
it's like she's the one who's acting out
and we're yelling at her for acting out
so Joe I need one of the things I wanted
to talk about is this is something that
has to change these people can't be the
ones who have to worry that if they tell
me or your friend that we're gonna look
at them like oh you're free got enough
to do with this you know because they're
the ones who are suffering for a very
long time and I think that keeps people
from speaking out because that fear of
being labeled I did they'd almost rather
keep it to themselves and not of other
people know that they've been molested
you they don't want to for you to be
uncomfortable around them right and
there was a girl in my high school
she told another girl that her brother
had been raping her for years and she
went to mom and mom says you know you're
talking about that can't happen but this
happens all the time and we don't have
the space to discuss it so I've just
been kind of talking about this a lot
more and encouraging people to talk
about this a lot more because it's
they're really really a lot of people
who are suffering because of this and
what do you do here's the big question
something like that what do you do to
help the person who's been molested and
what you do what do you do to the person
who molest someone well the person who
did it I I can't even begin I don't know
but I think what happens is just like
with gay rights right the more people
who come out and talk about it the more
easy it is for someone to call someone
else and be like this happened to me you
know what I'm going through let's have
this Congress
have you seen this very strange trend
that's rare but common enough and
actually predicted where people are
talking about people that are pedophiles
that it's some sort of a sexual
inclination that we should have yeah
sympathy for them because it's not-it's
nothing they asked for and it's no
different than being born gay or being
you it is just a thing where you're born
in a way that is there any science to
back that up at all I perfectly happy to
believe that people can be born with
this inclination I don't care if I
boards an inclination that I want to
murder people
well I better figure out how to deal
with this yeah you not I mean right and
I think that's a complete in many ways
red herring if it's something that they
can't change that doesn't that makes it
worse
that means you can't have no reason to
even just dangerous yeah right your
cannibal that can only mean right
vampire living amongst us right because
instead of stealing Souls you're
stealing someone's future and and the
thing about these types is they're very
common they're like any predator you're
gonna be drawn to where the resources
are so they're going to be
disproportionate in those fields where
you are interacting with your targets
right so that's what makes it so sick
it's not like you have these ideas okay
fine you can have whatever ideas you
want you were laying does that ground
work you know to prey on these kids and
you know what you're doing it's it's and
again I I don't know what to do with
this information but I do know that this
is really really bad and you know people
talk about this is the truest form of
being a victim there is and the sickest
part about it to me is how many of these
kids go on to molest other kids yeah
it's it's like like a disease like
they've got a disease I well I told Matt
that he should there's two ways right
they go on I told Matt you should
consider reaching out to this guy and
telling him you forgive him because he's
like because it's possible that you're
like 10 or 11 you're doing this you grow
up and you realize what you've done and
what this means and I don't know how you
could live with yourself it's well we
have to hope and assume that it ended
with that that he didn't continue doing
it as they get older and write with the
same
child yeah it's it's and what's even
worse what happens when it's within the
family right this happens I talked to
someone who's a former sheriff in the
when I was in the Midwest and you know
this was his job to helping these kids
he goes it is so much more prevalent
than you think and what happens is
families you know how back in the day
you'd want to talk with divorce because
it's shameful I didn't understand what
they were ashamed of whatever and now
it's like oh that's just crazy uncle
Nick keeping away from the kids it's
like that's not a thing that is the
uncle Nick yeah there's too many of us
already yeah the thing is like even
saying that there's too many of us we
should kill pedophiles like that's it's
if you put that up like in a real
intimate situation you're talking just a
bunch of people that really cared about
each other and were good friends like I
think we should kill pedophiles they'd
be like [ __ ] yeah but most people would
say yes but in public in public
discourse like saying she killed
pedophiles like okay but here's a
problem sometimes people get accused to
be in pedophiles and they're not like
you remember that school that uh there
was a daycare school and these kids were
actually being coached into saying the
little kids it was a famous case and
that eventually the case all fell apart
but not before these people's
reputations were ruined everything was
ruined their business was shattered all
because these kids had made stuff up and
then other people had liked coached him
into making more stuff up and then
everything got crazier and crazy what
was the name of that it was it was a
very famous case I mean they made a
documentary about it because it shows
almost like there's a mass hysteria that
can go on especially when you're talking
about something that's particularly
heinous right like the abduction and or
the rape of children rather because
we're all so scared of that being real
that we'll pay attention as much as
possible so they have these news stories
they have all these different things
that are attached to this and then
people keep probing and they keep you
asking questions and then it accelerates
and grows because it's a focal point of
attention but people start lying but
we're also so scared so we don't want to
think it could be true and we don't want
to thank either ones right true right
someone could molest kids or the kids
would be coached in the lawyer but I
most of them are horrible I'm much more
concerned with people who are dealing
with this and how they can get yes of
course no of I think that I'm saying
that's why you can't kill them
okay I'm not advocating killing anybody
I'm just advocating for people and I
don't I'm not a victim of this I just
have a friend and again everyone I've
talked to knows someone one degree of
separation oh yeah and I'm just saying
for the people who had gone through this
just like Matt listening to the show hi
this is what I told him when I thought
my experience when people come to you in
a vulnerable way don't tell them what
you do you think they want to hear be as
vulnerable in return so I said to him I
don't Matt I don't care I don't think of
you any differently I don't think you're
damaged I don't think you're a freak I
think it's awful I can't relate to this
at all I know you're glad I can't relate
to this at all and I think it's great
that you want me to kind of talk about
this to stop someone from blowing their
brains out yeah this is again it's again
do you are you like it's hard for me and
have a much smaller audience than you to
be aware of the reach of the show
because I'll get letters from people
being like oh I'm going through chemo
and I read your Twitter to make my day
and I'm like I can't take pride in that
because I'm in my underwear being an
[ __ ] on Twitter and that's
independent of you kind of you know
getting your laughs oh thank you but it
doesn't resonate so for your level I
mean this kind of saved my buddy's life
because of jake the snake' on this show
that's beautiful I'm very happy that
that happened
and that's a wonderful side effect but
if I thought about that only it would
never be the same thing okay the reason
why I think the show works is Comfort
like a comfort level and talking to
people and and having fun and enjoying
it and I think the moment you start
thinking about your reach okay and the
amount of impact that it has how many
people are actually listening at the
same time you'll start freaking out and
you'll never be as comfortable you won't
be comfortable like what people like
listening to is people that like like
you and I are friends we tell us a few
times I enjoy your company thank you no
I do just jokes pal they're jokes but
you know that I think you're very funny
and very smart and I enjoy your company
so when we're together I'm like this is
great I'm gonna sit down with Michael
we're gonna talk we're gonna have a good
time it's gonna be fun I'm enjoying this
like that is what one of the things that
people like they like the fact that
friends joke around and they're
comfortable with each other and we could
just change subjects and talk about
anything
and I think the moment you read you
almost like you have to hypnotize
yourself to not look at the big picture
you have to sort of like just stay in
the pocket stay in the pocket just be
yourself just all this craziness is
around you like oh gotta get away from
that go over this way yeah yeah but
don't don't live in it yeah every single
time I leave this room I'm like oh [ __ ]
what did I say because because you can't
be on for this long
I know but me to do ten thousands of
yeah I mean think about all the stupid
[ __ ] I've said there's no way around it
so no it's busting 70 percent of the
time of my [ __ ] the podcast right before
this one so you know that doesn't I've
said some terrible stupid things hi and
not even exactly sure what I'm saying
while I'm saying it I'm like no no
that's um what I meant [ __ ] it's a fun
way to do it though it's like oh you
know it's like skiing downhill and
you're not sure if you could stop have
you tried the new ones like moxie and t
x6 or something what new weed no there's
new types of like psychedelics oh you're
over that [ __ ] I don't need that the
stuff that's real is good enough these
people want to try something other than
mushrooms like what are you looking for
I asked it's not strong enough for you I
don't think it there's one that you
could turn off
oh you turn it off yeah like with a
switch no like you know I kept you're
drunk you can kind of make yourself
sober so you need to so this is a
psychedelic that you can switch off oh
what's it called amok so doc see it's
5ma oh yeah am i and then to see bees
the other one I've heard of to see beef
yacon you saw I was that from the
contest and the log of the more popular
drug five Meo dipt foxy mocks foxy
missus great it's got an old-time you
name
I've never interesting foxy methoxy is a
great name hmm
so it's like I guess hipster mushrooms
you probably haven't heard of it well
they're always coming up with new things
to avoid certain drug tests where they
just alter a chemical rice slightly it
doesn't that's where five Meo DMT was
not qualified as one of the Bands
psychedelics in the 1970s sweeping
psychedelic act and and
dimethyltryptamine was was labeled five
Meo is DMT with an oxygen molecule
attached to it which eliminates some I
don't know
exactly how it works but the visuals are
very different it looks very different
feels very different it's way more
potent and it was legal forever like you
could order it in the year 2000 s we
would get it from a [ __ ] chemical
company where you ordered over the
Internet and they would send you like a
aspirin bottle of the [ __ ] and you could
literally put the entire city on the
moon with that astronaut little aspirin
oh my god that's amazing
it was so potent and it's this white
pure powder that is like straight from
this lab pharmaceutical grade
pharmaceutical grade not for human
consumption five methoxy
dimethyltryptamine and we we took it it
just puts you in the center of the
[ __ ] universe you feel like you're a
part of every cell and every atom and
every neutron every everything you're
part of everything you're in the soup of
it all there's no detachment between you
and things yeah yeah everything just
wall you disappear for like 15 minutes
you're sure you're dead
you're absolutely 100% sure you're dead
and it probably is what happens when you
die and then you come out of it you're
like what in the [ __ ] like I just got
that from a company that is order that
with a Visa Card like it's crazy this is
pre PayPal this was uh you you'd be able
to just buy this stuff like there was a
host of these different things like do
you remember salvia oh yeah we just
talked about today's that's the legal or
not I don't know it's a good question
because it's kind of falling out of
favor it's not something that people
talk about a lot but when people found
out that you could just get salvia from
a headshot yeah head shops are supposed
to be you can buy bongs you could buy
velvet posters but there's nothing that
he can get you [ __ ] up but then they
started selling salvia because it was
somehow under the legal and it is one of
the most mind-blowing psychedelics known
to man for ten minutes yeah it's [ __ ]
unbelievably powerful
Ari Shaffir did some on a podcast and he
lived an alternative life for three
months he had a family he had jobs he
had friends and then all of a sudden he
came back to reality and it was like
what in an alternate reality Ari Shaffir
his friends yes his friends in real life
I was different friends that I didn't
even know he just went into this place
and lived another life I think he was
under the ocean - yeah there he is right
there oh he's gone and he was getting
red
of course filmed it and so he was very
violent when he woke up to Oh like
violet violet you know rumor is
everybody was [ __ ] because this is
disorienting
yeah he's convinced you're physically
paralyzed yeah so he was he's like get
off me get off me Sam trip please
because sunglasses on it was chaos
anyway he he came out of it and he said
that while he was out for ten minutes he
lived like three months in a different
world Jesus Christ and then you have to
wonder if that's the real one and this
is the fake one Wow am I wrong no you're
not wrong that's what apparently when
you would have the Catholic priests
going down the aisle waving that would
either be sage which is I think pleading
derivative of salvia divinorum I think
not a derivative a cousin maybe a close
relative I think sage and salvia
divinorum are extremely close okay in
terms of like the genes-- genus genus
what's the genus for sage I think it's
real close I think it's it's one of
those things where they think that maybe
people were burning that but they were
probably also most definitely burning
cannabis and so they were wafting
through the aisles with cannabis smoke
getting everybody secondhand high huh
yeah and that's one have that experience
yeah to take them into this [ __ ]
Catholic journey you know the guys were
in a robe just but [ __ ] disco these
stained glass windows everywhere like
holy [ __ ] and look at the the epic
structure yeah you're looking at these
gigantic beautiful artworks that they're
calling buildings sage or salvia okay
all stages of salvia Wow
over time though the term sage has been
closely aligned with cooking or
medicinal use and the term salvia has
been given to more ornamental members of
the genes-- genus nevertheless salvia is
the latin name or genus given to all
these plants yeah so sage is salvia so
salvia divinorum this incredibly potent
psychedelic is common sage Wow or close
and evasive species yeah yeah in the
neighborhood of it and it's like a mix
of acid and no we look at those guys
tripping balls son those guys are
walking around with salvia blowing
salvia smoke that that's not a
coincidence man they could have picked
[ __ ]
cedar bark they chose the month some
super potent psychedelic and wafted
through the air as they're walking back
and forth there's also that theory that
this Salem witch trials are because
they're all eating her God yes from in
their head and early Frost yeah early
yeah early Frost yeah they think that
that apparently is a really good one
like they really think that that really
could have been at well they also
there's a book called the Oracle about
the Oracle at Delphi right and she had
these visions and she would prophesy the
future and they went there and they
found that they found her stool she was
sitting over who or her stool as she
said it's got three legs to it yeah yeah
yeah I thought like an animal got a cup
what's it called sample cough bro what's
the thing for dinosaur poo fossilized
copper or something oh they can get
those um dinosaur poo yeah
fossilized yeah yeah it's she so they
found she was sitting over a crack well
with natural gas coming out so she's
getting high off of whatever that is oh
no [ __ ] so there was no gas leaking out
through the ground where she was
partying yeah so of course she's gonna
be speaking gibberish and having all
these visions cuz she's gettin it's like
pop it's like not like like I'm like
when you what's with the Whitney we
inhale the yeah yeah and laughing gas
when you go to the haha yeah Oh nitrous
it totally makes sense yeah I think
that's probably a lot of these cases of
course wacky things that people did I
mean it only makes sense I mean they
never did figure out what soma is in the
ancient Hindu is that right yeah yeah
they they think it might have been some
kind of psycho dog but they don't know
what like there's all this different
speculation like some people think it
was a combinatorial a siphon mixed with
something else and lotus flower there's
all these like different different
theories but nobody really knows but
soma was obviously something that they
were taking as a sacrament that would
have these profound effects that's most
likely the root of all of these crazy
religious experiences these people were
tripping their [ __ ] balls off and
they weren't lying that God did come to
them oh yeah yeah God did come to him
out of the burning bush and spoke to
them that's the other thing that the
burning bush they think that these
scholars in Jerusalem think that the
burning bush is probably the acacia bush
which
is rich in DMT oh so that's probably why
this is the the metaphor right though
the burning bush and God spoke to them
in the burning bush that's probably what
it really means
they were tripping but they were smoking
it tripping balls and they met God and
he came back with it this is the only
way we're gonna get along gotta stop
raping each other
and the other thing is a lot of these
old mystery religions right you have to
be initiating to them yeah and if you're
gonna join this cult or whatever for
lack of a better term and they give you
here take this you are going to
experience something not only that no
one ever that you've ever heard of right
but like you don't even know how to
handle it yeah it's it's will change
your life permanent but there's no
vocabulary for it there it's not like
now we're you know what acid is you're
like holy [ __ ] this is religious right
you would think it's God
yeah met God yeah unless it's bad when
you meet the devil you know about that
guy John Marco Allegro you know we know
he's ago deciphered the Dead Sea Scrolls
oh okay he worked on the panel for 14
years and he wrote Oh sewer seriously
controversial book he was an ordained
minister but he was the only one on the
Dead Sea scroll translation group that
they put together that was agnostic cuz
he started studying well he was he was a
ordained minister but then he started
studying theology and it was all crazy
like what is this so he became agnostic
and he wanted to look at the etymology
of the words and so he it was his
conclusion after 14 years that the
entire Christian religion was a gigantic
misunderstanding and what it really was
about was psychedelic mushroom
experiences and fertility rituals okay
and he broke down the word Jesus to an
ancient word that an ancient Sumerian
word that means a mushroom covered in
God's semen and the idea was that the
the rain which would make everything
grow with God's come and that it wasn't
a bad thing like they didn't think of
come as bad they wanted to live
everybody wanted wanted to have children
they wanted a prosperous yeah and that
when the rain would come mushrooms would
appear almost instantaneously like have
you ever seen yeah and when they would
eat those they would trip their [ __ ]
balls off so they had decided that this
was Jesus and that this this this was
what his godson yeah God created this
from his own seed well this is what mark
Legros his research was point two he was
trying to say that what was really going
on was these people were trying to hide
a lot of what the psychedelic rituals
are from the Romans and from the people
that capture them
so they hid them in stories and parables
and there was all sorts of problems in
the translations there's just like you
know you're taking things from ancient
Hebrew and you're breaking it down to
Latin and you break it a down day German
and English and I can't I can't believe
he got a positive reception for this if
you're not didn't necessarily he the
book got bought out okay by the Catholic
Church and then recently reinstated and
then not out it they bought it they like
the I think they took it off the market
I think you used to be able to only get
a copy of it used to only be able to get
a like a used copy okay and then Yan
Irvin put it out here II published it
like a few I don't know honestly maybe
eight ten years ago so now you get a
hold but he also published another book
after they took that one look back what
I think I don't know that the total
history of it but he published a second
book and the second book was the Dead
Sea Scrolls and the Christian myth and
the first one was a sacred mushroom in
the cross Wow but it only makes sense if
you think about people who lived back
then and we know that psychedelic
mushrooms aren't recent existed forever
right so these people found them and
they most certainly did
yes there's a lot of depictions of them
and there's also a lot of iconography a
lot of like you see shapes that resemble
mushrooms like all over the place and
some of the ancient artwork and even
people that are dancing naked under the
influence of a mushroom so there's a
translucent mushroom shape that
surrounds them and these ancient
paintings and these religious paintings
these people are dancing so most likely
they were trippin balls well if you
didn't know any better of course you
would think that's God talking to you if
you didn't know what psilocybin is you
didn't know what dimethyltryptamine is
you know what any of these things are
well you're also gonna hear voice
literal voices yes literally so it's not
even that you're like it's not a
metaphor you're gonna hear a voice
talking to you
right so people that think that like
these people who created religion were
all liars
they're probably more likely tripperz
because if you look at all these
religious stories they're all crazy
weird and fantastical and wonderful but
most of them are like guides to live
life in a more virtuous or pious or
moral way right that's what most sure
what the tenets of a lot of religions
well that's what you get when you trip
you when you you trip you you get you
got to be a better person yeah that's
what you get you get this like profound
human shouldn't see humiliation but
humbling in the face of this Titanic
expression in an experience that you
can't even describe with words and then
after it's over you want to be a better
person and there's also a sense of
comfort yeah it's gonna be okay which is
what religion traditionally gives a lot
of people like a sense of reassurance
that someone's looking out you're not
gonna accidentally you know don't even
that it's so you get a feeling that even
if it's not okay it's okay right like
when you die it's okay yeah when you
trip balls like one of the things that
Larry Hagman say remember Larry Hagman
from Dallas that is I will say Dallas is
probably the greatest show of all time
great fall control that is and people
confused with dynasty which was trashy
garbage Dallas was one of the region's
because I think it's literally the best
show of all time like what's his name
jr. what was Jerry doing
that's right well he trip balls and
talked about it on CNN and said that it
was one of the best experiences of his
life because he no longer was afraid of
death that before that he was afraid of
death and the one thing that tripping
and tripping hard apparently really did
for him that he no longer held that fear
and he had stared death in the face
because of Zach holism you know you have
a liver transplant or ever was so it was
no joke
he was a huge alcoholic he had a dope
house that was for sale in Topanga and
unfortunately I wasn't in the market for
a house but I would love to buy that
guy's house that show had I think the
funniest line of all time which is
Victoria Principal who was like the good
was Pam comments his office she's the
good guy right and she's yelling at jr.
and he would look at her with a straight
face like he would never wink and he I'm
gonna get it backwards or he goes Pam
I've always thought you were stupid I
never made any you know mistake about
that but I never thought you were crazy
too it was just like holy SH a little
beast who's a good bad guy yes one of
the first bad guys on TV like Tony
Soprano type dudes oh yeah like rooted
for right because
the show the villain was cliff Barnes so
it was about a evil person versus a bad
in the sense of low-quality person his
enemy wasn't a good person he was just
this loser who was jealous of jr. so it
was very smart to have bad versus evil
as opposed to good versus bad yeah it
was so good good [ __ ] show yeah back
in the day when there's only like five
shows on TV yeah five chant four
channels if that during jr. wasn't that
three it was three Fox came later yes no
no it I mean it lasted from what 78 to
1990 I think so Fox was around by then
but yeah yeah Fox was around when I was
in high school that's what's crazy about
the Simpsons Simpsons was on from day
one it was so good there so you think
it's watchable yes it's like fan fiction
you still watch it love it do you still
watch it if it comes on I see it I want
you to rerun er the new one whatever is
on I'm not picky okay I'm very picky the
old ones were amazing the old ones
remember my favorite one ever it was in
Homer ate the hot peppers that went into
that [ __ ] dream boy there's a shock
twist that's your favorite episode I saw
that but yeah it was so off the charts
weird have you ever done the ride at
Universal no it's that it's all main way
damn the Homer peppered right they have
a full on virtual reality ride at
Universal Studios based on The Simpsons
and is one of my favorite rides of all
time okay it's [ __ ] amazing yeah I'll
give you some spoiler alerts okay the
little kid becomes giant a lot of crazy
[ __ ] happens explosions you're on a
roller coaster
it's nuts it's so fun good okay it's so
good so good okay it's psychedelic it's
chaos it's it's The Simpsons
that's they've never seen it no I'm
gonna pull up a video of what it looks
like to ride I think it used to be the
Back to the Future I didn't it oh is
that it hmm I think so what they least
ran it the same way I don't think it's
big Marty it's a part of the thing like
maybe they have both there and they go
back I don't know I'm just talking to
ass right now I don't really have no
idea if it's true
I remember the Back to the Future right
to not you thinking about it apparently
they just redid the jurassic park ride
to that's supposed to be cool but the
Simpsons Ride is amazing
so good it's so good because it's all
virtual you're not going anywhere you're
sitting still but you swear to god
you're gonna your honor though you're
flying it's it like one of those where
the seat moves to and such [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] and you're you're in front of
this massive high-definition screen yeah
yeah and incredible graphics do you mean
the glasses on - I don't think you do oh
okay I don't remember though I don't
remember I did something like that was
really cool
this the best one the best one is the
Avatar one at Disneyworld okay it's
flights of passion that's [ __ ]
incredible
that's so total next level I saw some
Disney dorks on YouTube reviewing like
the new Star Wars ride that just opened
up they said it's very close to if not
maybe better than that Wow I don't know
like what the ride was or what they did
but blasphemy I'm sure it's good it's
supposed to be 20 minutes long - oh it's
a new Star Wars this is this is the
Simpsons ride like a bunch of stuff
happens to you yeah you played here so
all this crazy [ __ ] is happening right
in front of you and you're it's just fun
it's just a it's a really good one Oh
dope it's really fun dude oh and it's
coming right at you yeah yeah and
they're there at this time for the chair
shaking yeah yeah yeah yeah it's crazy
it was so much fun
what was the other one we were just
looking at oh the Disneyworld
avatar ride the Disneyworld avatar ride
you clot you climb onto this thing that
looks like a motorcycle okay and then
they put goggles on you but this hug
helmet and strap you in place literally
lock your legs in place and all sudden
you're on a dragon and you're on a
dragon in Avatar and it's oh this is a
full HD virtual reality you get smells
and wind and everything oh it's so good
dude it's so good it's so good when it's
over you like five I want to live there
people just want to get right back in
line
do it again yeah oh that I haven't
gotten a good ride in a long time it
made me really think and I the first
time I did it was I think two years ago
but it made me really think like this is
gonna get real weird because if they can
do this now oh yeah
ten years from now what the [ __ ] is it
going to be like I was at the gas
Digital Studios and Ralph's had these 3d
glasses and it's basically you have to
like take an elevator and then you're
walking in the street and like there's a
part where there's like a wooden plank
and they put a wooden plank in real life
on the side not in the carpet and I was
scared we have that right here yeah it's
terrifying yeah it's crazy I did it the
other day and then the the plank
disappeared yeah yeah yeah then you like
see them yeah yeah yeah you start
falling to the ground it's it's [ __ ]
up you know how they tell you when
you're a kid if you die in your dreams
you die in real life which doesn't make
any sense how would you know but that's
what this feels like it does feel like
that yeah whoo the [ __ ] knows that you
darn your dreams yeah I force myself to
die my dream [ __ ] I'll show you I'll
die imagine if they made an Alex Honnold
one an Alex Honnold he's that climber
from free solo the guy who free solo
climbs like oh Jesus yeah that's no joke
faces oh my god we were just talking
about him the I even discussing him
lightly makes my hands wet how did I
don't know I just I don't understand how
he conquers that it's he's suicidal no
not at all no he's gone wrong he's just
really good he knows he can do it i but
yeah this there's chaos theory comes in
at a certain point right like if you're
if I'm fighting somebody a billion times
at one time I'm gonna land that punch to
take him out yes but in his look at that
yeah different guy but it's the same
spot okay that's the same spot he just
did it
that's a just fits this cuz they're
going vertically up side they're going
horizontally upside down right so crazy
the fact that someone even can do that
blows my [ __ ] mind but the fact that
someone can do that 2,000 feet above the
ground is just insane that is insane so
there's a route that you have to go
through and as you're going through that
route you got to continually chalk your
hands and shove them into this crack and
slowly make your way up and he first
ascended it I know I'm so sweaty
he first ascended it with ropes he marks
okay and he makes his detailed analysis
and then he ascends that I'm sure it
sends it with ropes without actually
using the ropes and knows that you know
so that they're okay so there's a lot of
work that goes into this look it doesn't
lock
look at that fall and he's got big-ass
gorilla hands
he's like a thin wiry guy with these
meats like a sausage hands that's a
trick rocks a bright good smell in the
hands of gigantic yeah well they're very
muscular
I mean he's [ __ ] just climbing and
pulling himself and he could I'm sure he
could do like fingertip push-ups yeah
yeah hold up pull-ups brother and his
back must be insane insane
yeah and he's light you know you have to
stay light well that's the thing with
the proportion right because if you put
on too much muscle mass that's gonna be
it's it's this weird delicate dance that
they got to do they had the best
climbers I was something I've been
following recently because I got into
these Alex Honnold videos and then I
didn't know bouldering I was like what
they call it they call it Boulder okay
but these the best guys that do this are
these really almost anorexic looking
guys that are just super shredded like
they have there's no weight right like
no extra weight anywhere and there's
this gym I forget where the gym was some
climbing gym where they doing all these
different exercises and chin-ups and and
and planks and stuff while hanging off
of two fingers so they're doing it thank
two finger chin-ups and they're doing
two finger champs where they literally
literally like hold and extend their
legs in front of them like and then pull
themselves up and like and and basically
do like a muscle up yeah two fingers
like hanging on a rock face like there's
also some little asian girl who does all
this stuff she's like twelve and she's
like a spider monkey no what no she's
too young
get it down well I don't know how old
she is twelve fourteen but it's it I
mean you see you're climbing like this
and it's just it just I'm just amazing
I'm just glad I could do pull-ups now
before [ __ ] those [ __ ] people like
that that jolt of satisfaction when you
get to the top of a mountain like that
oh my god what are you doing sir that's
gonna break off that thing's barely
hanging on and this guy's like oh I'm
just gonna climb it bro [ __ ] [ __ ] that
[ __ ] everything about that this is just
for Instagram to get that good and
people are falling man you know like a
bunch of people fell in Yellowstone did
they know Grand Canyon bunch of people
fell in the Grand Canyon like an
unusually high number lately
is preposterous the fact that this
person can even do this that woman but I
think it's come on it must be easier
wouldn't she's alright what you can do
with you use your legs that way above
the ground very high okay look I don't
give a [ __ ]
pretend it is pretend it is I mean she
if they can do that I mean how often do
they fall [ __ ] that thing [ __ ] getting
under that thing either by the way I'm
not even gonna camp under that thing
it's not long for this world look how
much it sticks out that's crazy get out
of there man yeah we've all seen enough
Wiley coyote cartoons to say he's gonna
look down and it's gonna be the end of
it what does that call for people
Jamie's called the Rhino or something
Rocklin South Africa rock climbing it
says yeah the Rhino right yeah [ __ ] that
dude I saw there's a nature's metal post
that I saw where there was a hyena pack
broke into a safari there like a safari
camp and killed a kudu in the middle of
the lobby so like these people are like
really getting the safari experience
like in the lobby of the place where
they're staying to go on safari a pack
of hyenas slaughters a [ __ ] kudu
hyenas are the most fun look at that
look at that oh my god oh my god imagine
we're gonna go see some elephants and
it'll be amazing and a pack of hyenas
just turn that [ __ ] place into a
slaughterhouse what do you call a group
of hyenas do we know is it a pack
it's a term it's gotta be like a Lancer
of hyena so there's a weird term yeah
yeah and the females are transgender yes
well they're not trans - and no larger
is a lot in your gorged litters large
their battery Arkell - so they're bigger
than the male yeah I have a whole bit
about that like female bodybuilders did
you know that 60% of all hanging a baby
suffocate to death
no how well birth why 60% cuz they come
out of the dick what the females have a
dick right the babies have to come out
of the dick know if splits open yep
really 60% suffocate to death go like
hackle cackle okay technical turn is a
cackle they're usually referred to as
pax go back to that picture they also
get tamed pretty easily I went to a zoo
where they had a pair of them they were
very sweet
cuz if you feed them yeah but they're
smart you know I mean yes but they'll
try to [ __ ] up lion's mane no they steal
from the Lions [ __ ] [ __ ] they're like
gangsters because there's a whole gang
of them and the lines like alright
they're like no no we were doing this
nothing taking that bite the Lions - you
try to eat them they're their gangster
when they're all together but look at
that picture man that is so insane
that's gonna be one funny yelp review
imagine coming downstairs for some
coffee you know newspaper early today
we're gonna go see some giraffes oh
Jesus
I would watch Jesus I'd want dibs on
those horns wow they are playing those
horns man really yeah they're shooting
those things left and right oh yeah that
thing what is that back that up Jamie it
said there's more info on their story oh
the Unicorn
look at that thing it's got three horns
what is that is it three dudes yeah yeah
oh my god what the [ __ ] what is that
okay the first one middle horns gotta be
four it's got a deformity if you told me
that that was an animal I'd be like [ __ ]
off that's not a real animal go back to
that thing what is that take Jamie it's
the you um what is it called
it's a Kuip of cow isn't it three-horn
well not the three-horn i think the
whole third horns are deformity no
animals three horns okay so that's just
a rare one must look at the water
buffalo horns but it looks so perfect no
the water buffalos are curved their
weight above your head oh those yeah
yeah yeah that's that thing well no no
it's not this is like a Texas thing
that's a Texas thing no ready the cow
broke it does a very car you know what
stop that might be [ __ ] go back to
that I stuck it on there ya go
they don't wanna camp keys you know put
your cursor on that and pause it no no
not like a phone dude that looks fake
look what's going to middle face does it
that is a cow I told you yeah are you
sure it's a cow I'm not sure no look at
the back that's not a cow yeah there's
they have those homes that do they call
that a dewlap but really like that yeah
what's the cause EBU is it a zebu really
got a lot of deformities it could be a
zebu it's maybe I saw one of those in
real life with the two horns and it's
just like the net talk about the neck
strength it's just so yeah I typed it in
another picture that exact picture came
out of what three horn cow so my just
physical component and Kohli Watusi okay
modern American breed of a domestic
okay whoa yeah it's not not an American
they call it a wah to see how rude that
picture down there there's another one
with three horns right below you well or
not look at that one so really it's not
that's not realizing I had put on it
yeah a second cap or dunce cat's a cap -
oh this is the one from Uganda I don't
know if it's so problem sometimes when
animals get an injury yeah - their bone
plate they'll they'll branch off like
elk
you'll have like they'll fight with each
other is how real but that well that's a
uncommon deformity people have horns
like sometimes elk fight with each other
and they stab each other in the head and
yeah stab each other in the head it
breaks the pedicle and then it splits
off into two different directions so
you'll have instead of like that well
you have two main beams that come out of
the animal's head you'll have two main
beams and then a third so the third one
look like a spear and on the the one
that has two there will be no points
it'll just be these Spears that grow
straight up with with no no additional
points the same thing with lots of like
plants you can top the cap off and
there's gonna grow two or four branches
yes exactly exactly nature finds a way
yeah but look at that I got a for me
that happens sometimes mmm okay that's
pretty dope why do I like that better
than two let's see look at the one the
right to the left that's that's what I
was talking about that's the yeah see
but here's the thing if they all have
three and that one had two I'd be like
two is better it looks more symmetrical
three looks stupid yeah I don't share
cows didn't have three horns yeah what's
this was the middle horn what's the
benefit of that better way to [ __ ] you
up did it yeah do they sell them well
that was the thing about one of the
ranches that I was on they had one of
these animals that an elk that had
broken antlers okay
a broken pedicure or whatever whatever
they said ago right medical yeah that's
right
and I knew it sounded wrong and it was
branching off and forming these Spears
so it was [ __ ] killing all these
other elk oh because instead of clashing
and locking up like all these antlers do
where they have all these additional
points yeah what they do is they lock it
yeah yeah this would slide right through
and stab him in the heart and stab and
stab them in the body so
one elk was killing everybody that's it
go to war with him you just kill them
that's the Alpha an injury yeah well
that's also evolution at work oh yeah
yeah well it's not gonna be genetics I
can't pass it on
I wonder I wonder if eventually over
many many many many many generations
like that that signal will somehow or
another get through I mean obviously
something happens where they developed
or sat in the first place yes if if it
became better that they branched off in
some new way that lets you stab each
other a little bit better
those those animals would breed better
yeah or yeah crazy some things that
grows in a couple of months but they
also said it right said it at the end of
the summer and the winter they have
nothing on their head for a couple
months and then it starts growing again
and it grows like wildfire is it isn't
it surprising we like cuz it's like it's
heavy as hell that's heavies [ __ ] that's
bone man ok there's different kinds of
bone fish birds that bone that's not
even big that's a mule deer that's small
ok but that's that's heavy
but I have an elk skull out there that
you can pick up pick that [ __ ] thing
up you like holy [ __ ] that's why if you
look at a bowl elk have giant necks yeah
yeah huge next cuz all that muscle carry
all that weight around yeah they're cool
to look at they're dope I went down a
rabbit hole of getting all kinds of
animal stuff it's kind of fun getting
animal stuff yeah I mean like that pen I
showed you made smaller cool I got where
did you get that where'd you get a pen
made out of mammoth mold um you could
just say yes you're very good thank you
I've got uh what do I got it for tight
that's a real mammoth more yeah cuz
mammoth isn't protected because they're
extinct so you can trade mammoth ivory
and mammoth teeth very easily dirty yeah
this is sweet dude yeah so make those
pen some guy an Instagram I'm blanking
on his name does it make you feel more
important when you're writing with
something that's like from an animal how
could I feel more important good point
you're good it does it's kind of fun
because the fans paid for it so it's
like I mean this is cool yeah that's
beautiful you are you still in compound
media I am I've got my show nightshade
there and my other show I interview
people's you're welcome it's my friend
Anthony days great yes Dave land I was
covering from you today so beautiful
okay
so you can be here with us that's right
yeah have a fun vacation in California
how long you staying for I'm leaving
tonight at 11:00 uh you know bang bang
no I got here at Thursday what'd you do
i you know ii think sup leas why dont
he's a character actor American history
ten Boy Meets World who's just didn't
know American History X I mean that was
the joke my friends are all right yeah
my name is Aaron so he has a new podcast
talking about fitness and body issues I
think that he's a great dude I saw
Bridger fantasy who has been on your
show yeah she's great we recorded all so
yeah she's hilarious she's one of my
favorite Twitter follows I'm having
dinner with her tonight
beautiful I will and my favorite place
here in LA is the Museum of Jurassic
technology so that was from Jurassic
technology yet the Museum of Jurassic
technology what is it you don't know
what this is it's so Joe Rogan really oh
my god it's dedicated to the lower
Jurassic so basically it's a museum
about museums and you go there and
you're looking through [ __ ] and you're
like I don't know if this is real so
they have exhibits about like Antonius
kerscher who's from the 1300s who said
the world is tied with secret knots and
using magnetism to prove God then they
have microscopes where people someone
used butterfly scales to make images on
that kind of level they have exhibits
about cat's cradle
they have exhibits about their their
apps
oh yeah there's there's the microscopes
you're not allowed to go use cameras in
there so it just keeps unwinding
unwinding unwinding and I'm a very Willy
Wonka person and you're in there and
you're like this is absolutely magical
oh yeah yeah they I've got a room that's
horns from a woman apparently what yeah
yeah yeah
that Greta woman said but you know back
in the day museums half the [ __ ] was
fake so you're in there and you're
wondering what is this real or is this
not they have an exhibit now dice that
are falling apart like dice that are
dying and they've been exhibit on mobile
homes of California so I love that point
where it's in Culver City no [ __ ] I've
never heard anybody talk about really
yeah of you dude it's the best place in
LA look at that look at the stars - it
is what point are stars on Google and
you go in there and you don't know what
the hell you're looking at it's like too
close though
yeah but I was just there yesterday it's
amazing Oh Monday it's closed Wednesday
it's closed or Tuesday Tuesday is closed
yeah that's crazy
everybody open Thursday Friday Saturday
and Sunday what if I want to find out
about cool [ __ ] on Monday
well yeah Internet they need to have a
better business model well I I mean it
is ridiculous people like museums on
Monday Tuesday Wednesday LA everything
is closed on Monday I wanted to go to
cool art galleries I had a whole good
list and they're all closed in ruin even
the brode is closed you should go to the
LACMA yeah LACMA is terrible it's a
terrible it's a disaster well they're
rebuilding it it's but it's not what
it's not what's a disaster what's the
disaster is what they call art oh
there's a plexiglass box it's on the
ground it's just an amber box
no seriously oh yeah oh yeah and I go
what is that and then well dudes open
for your interpretation oh yeah artists
put in like there's a line like a wire
around the thing you can't pass through
I'm like why can't I sit on the box like
no that's a piece of art like you're
kidding but you're really oh yeah it's
so Dom it makes you angry okay and then
there's another art exhibit that was
videos of people playing catch like
that's it Oh Mike you're not joking no
I'm not joking that stupid [ __ ] thing
is just sitting there people like oh my
god brilliant thank ya oh my god amazing
amazing that makes me sad because there
is so much good contemporary art like
that what's that what is that like the
paintings though in the back the middle
yeah what's pretty cool oh well there's
definitely some cool [ __ ] yeah but when
I saw that amber box
I got violent all right we're out of
here yeah done yeah angry like you made
me pay money and I'm gonna see this
[ __ ] amber box like really you like
at all the art I do all the art that you
put that on the bottom you put it on the
floor so people could stare it in the LA
well uz levar you know what it is it
basically turns the audience into
performance artists because everyone
looks at it and or you or you or your
loser [ __ ] so you got triggered I didn't
get triggered those like oh boy my kids
but they were like what is that I go
it's the box say why we have a box I
think that's the art there's a
is the box like they were angry I think
there's an art to angering children oh
for sure yeah yeah they're hilarious
before talking about this box the more I
like it it's so goddamn dumb it made me
angry
well look what about marcel duchamp in
the urinal like what is that over a
hundred years ago Marcel Duchamp was a
painter right and they were having
exhibit and they asked him to contribute
something he goes alright
he takes a urinal puts it on the thing
and goes it's called fountain and they
didn't know what the [ __ ] to do so they
finally included it but behind the
curtain house walls yeah yeah those
[ __ ] art [ __ ] well the art world
is a weird world man yeah I don't know
it it'll catch fire they become hot and
then you look at their stuff and you're
like I went over this guy's house he
owned an agency in in LA I mean a big
house in Aspen the [ __ ] beautiful
house and he had this thing on his wall
it looked like a six-year-old took some
tissue paper of different colors and
glue them and some weird [ __ ] shape
so I said hey man is that did your your
kid do that and this agent goes that's
actually a blah blah blah it's a blah
blah I go what you mean like that I'm
wait a minute don't take money for this
yeah he said it's worth $30,000 I go
that's worth $30,000 back what about the
guy who takes Mickey Mouse and puts X's
over his eyes and his paintings sold for
like ten million you know talking about
could keep that keep that house like
he's got one word name and he's just
some dude and he makes Simpsons and just
puts across the cause-cause WS good have
you seen this guy no look at his look at
his art experience come on Mike why you
make me dumb I heard something about
this reset I don't know if it's accurate
because it sounds like a juicy truth but
I could also could be easily disproven
that that what you're saying that like
jacked up prices of art is some like
rich person scammed for like tax evasion
sort of oh I'm thinking like it's a
write-off I think is a little really
hard then they can donate it to a
company and they cannot pay taxes but
they can donate a twenty million dollar
I'm sure I'm sure there's some of that
I'm sure however I know people
that are these art collector folks that
buy this stupid stuff and they have it
all over the [ __ ] house and they want
to tell you what it is where it came
from it's a thing it's like buying wine
that costs a thousand dollars a bottle
there's people that are into that
they're gonna showing it to you and
they're into look at this watch it's
from the 16th century there's people
that are into that [ __ ] and they love
the fact that they have some unusual
piece of art on their wall and they love
the sophisticated feeling they get by
describing what the artist is trying to
say see I have this guy Sean cha chaa oh
I have he makes dioramas and I diorama
it's like a 3d sculpture you know it's
like a little scene and I have it right
over my desk because when I went to LA
like seven years ago I want to join
robot they had an exhibit in like this
is really cool and I'm one day I'm gonna
buy it and I bought it and now every day
I look at I'm like oh this is like
something I really wanted but it was
like a grand
it wasn't like 30 grand where and anyone
can look at it and be like oh this just
makes me happy it's actually art yeah
Sean Chow is his name there's some art
there's oh wow it's fun that was pretty
cool yeah but that makes sense to me
right if that you can look at and you'll
understand why I do I enjoy it yeah I
get that
there's things I get yeah cuz that's not
tissues yeah this is a fun thing of fish
underwater yeah someone made something
yes with his hands and you're also
helping someone directly by buying his
product but here's where that's right
look at that that's pretty cool but
here's where the Hustle is when people
don't really like it but they pretend
they like it because it's the cool thing
to pretend you like I think it's more
they also there is same with clothes
like you're like a label [ __ ] it's like
oh this is a this it's like you just
wanted by the name what's up with the
sneakers the kids are wearing to have a
[ __ ] a green tag on them I was it was
explained to me I retell the boomers now
there's a green I'm not a boomer right
I'm a generation the Boomers a state of
mind
yeah okay cool this green tact
what is it off-white is that what it is
yeah so they have this green tag on this
pair I was buying a pair of Nikes from
my kid and they're like oh those are
off-white what's that with this green
thing yeah what did I go you leave that
on like [ __ ] you I'm not leaving this
stupid plastic tag on
no you don't leave that on what is it
people do that thing giant ass tag they
leave these stupid [ __ ] tags these
are huge they're cumbersome they look
dumb but little wear them on their shoe
it's part of the thing it's part of the
grant this person was trying to explain
it to me it's part of the brown look in
five years it's gonna go away why is it
here because it looks different no it
looks different you know it's like a
flag go up to these [ __ ] kids just
cut that off and go no we're about to go
to war they're making you soft and
stupid this is probably a plot by the
Russians and the Chinese and the
Iranians to try to make sure that our
kids grow dumber and dumber this is
probably something that was started out
on Instagram by one of those IRA
internet research agencies what's this
that's the people that make all the
propaganda from the Russian coal farms
the IRA you never heard of that I've not
heard of control but internet research
agency is a state funded organization
that's this huge group of people that
makes these they did you some hilarious
stuff there's a woman named Renee to
rest us she investigated this and
reported on it she came on the podcast
explain to me after I'd heard her on Sam
Harris's podcast but they did stuff like
they would have a fake blacklivesmatter
page that they started and then they
would argue with people like about black
lives matter and then they would
organize like a Texas separatism
meeting to meet they organized the Texas
separatism page they had a page and then
they organized a meeting a Facebook
meeting where these people would be
there at the same time as another media
set up between these Muslim people so
they'd have the Texas separatist on one
side of streets and the Muslims in the
other side street having a protest at
the exact same time like they were doing
[ __ ] like this on purpose and [ __ ]
with people and they did a Louis yeah
they did a lot of anti Hillary Clinton
stuff and a lot of like different like
like they would pretend that they're
black women as a black woman I cannot
vote for Hillary Clinton like she does
not represent us like yeah and they were
just sewing these seeds of discourse or
discord all throughout social medias
wonderful wacky social media page this
is kind of hilarious yeah the more
discord the better but it's of course
it's going to have
as soon as the government realized that
if you rile people enough enough they'll
engage and then they'll you can actually
shift opinion yeah yeah especially if
you're funny yes that's one of the
things about all these funny memes oh
yeah oh my god there that's I mean this
is this is why I'm very scared for the
Democrats because Joe Biden is might be
the nominee he does not have a good
social media team when when he had this
family photo for Halloween all I just
replied with a photo of a crack pipe
right and where's hunter hashtag was
trending and I'm like no matter what you
think of Joe Biden it is not acceptable
for his Twitter not to be able to handle
this anticipated especially because you
have someone who just tweeted his way
into the presidency three years ago yes
like where are the people who are
helping this guy you know with his
social media game yeah they can't help
them the the people that are mean and
funny like that are all Republicans this
is something about the beams that go
against Trump versus the means that go
for Trump like the pro Trump memes are
so much funnier yeah the left cat meme
is the thing they're not that good
we're not they're good one of my sameen
kind of humor one of my tweets became a
meme when your girl Tulsi took out
officer Harris and I said if there's one
thing a Hawaii knows its how to roast a
pig and that went wide I wonder if she
knows about that she knows shows she she
knows did she see it she saw it she saw
you know she's because I sent it to me
and I'll make sure she sees it okay
please I will I don't send it to her her
chief of communications whatever follows
me on Twitter oh yeah yeah perfect yes
yeah she's good I like her
well I didn't like her as a person I'm
just glad that now that Harris is gone
it's just gonna be hilarious for the
next year whoever it is well the Harris
thing was weird meant like that they
didn't know the stuff that you could
call her out on oh yeah that come on
that
tulsi did but tell she didn't even get
to the horrible stuff the horrible stuff
was when she was threatening single moms
with jail time I think their kids were
truant right imagine you're just barely
staying above water as a single mom and
you got to literally make your [ __ ]
children terrified that you're gonna go
to
in order for them to go to jail she was
laughing about that's how she got people
to go to jail
that's that's how she got people to go
to school and that's the thing is that I
don't think she actually cared I think
this was her means to further her
political career I think you're right
because when you are you could say a lot
of things about Joe Biden and I have on
Twitter to go on the stage and call him
a closet racist or imply that come on
like this is as I was she did the first
debate she goes oh you were against
bussing and he's like I was against it
on the federal level like what are you
talking about she's like ah blah blah
blah blahs like who are you fooling
cutely nasty nasty Pig she's done yeah
they're playing game when she when she
dropped out like the fans chipped in on
my livestream and I spent $400 on ham
and I did a ham tasting cuz the pig was
done oh it was a lot of fun have you
ever tried that like Spanish ham that
America two hundred dollars a pound
I have tried it it's made of eggs only
eat acorns yeah that's that stuff that
Chris Ryan brought in that's fantastic
it's really good astok yeah so yeah I've
had wild pigs and only acorns and it's
like ham is so good yeah wild pigs and
only acorns have a great smell to them
and it's dark it's like a dark meat oh
so good yeah I though I tried like 20
different kinds of ham and I loved every
minute of it yeah I know a dude who he
raises pigs and he feeds them hazelnuts
and chocolate yeah and the bacon and it
comes through yeah I don't understand
how and magical Jesus you got to feed
them mushrooms thick I don't know what
happened they're eating mush ripping
face why I guarantee you wonder if it
works what happens when pigs eat
psychedelic mushrooms they must break
down come on right I don't think so you
think it goes near our addicted to
something called the Amanita muscaria
that's a mushroom and the Amanita
muscaria is the Santa Claus well sure
okay why send a mushroom that's
connected to the myth of Santa Claus
how's that it's got a micro Reiser
relationship with coniferous trees okay
grows under pine trees it looks like a
shiny package think about pine trees
that we have we put in our [ __ ]
source and there's a little shiny
Patrick make sure this it's red and
white which is just like Santa Clauses
outfit yeah and reindeers love it and
they [ __ ] trip balls when they eat it
and they fly away really seriously it
was all shaman we used to come down
during like when they were telling
not eat these mushrooms shaman would
sneak into people's houses through the
[ __ ] chimneys only if you are nice
yeah just only if you're naughty because
they were watching the [ __ ] front
door so people climb down through the
chimney with a bag of mushrooms they
would all trip balls together Wow all
speculative what you can buy this this
these questions know you could pick it
yeah but many of them as scary as a
weird one okay it's a weird one that's
that's what it is
I've taken it before and it does
something but it doesn't do something as
profound as psilocybin but reindeer or
caribou I should say which is what a
reindeer is caribou love them that face
and there's another thing they do with
this they rain be reindeer apparently
will dive on your piss if you're in a
lodge and you're eating the Amanita
muscaria and you urinate outside you
have to be careful of reindeer because
they literally tackle you to try to get
to your piss because they smell it
because it smells so potent so people
actually when they trip balls they get a
second high by drinking their own piss
so they're tripping balls they piss into
this glass and they drink their own pee
yeah because it's gonna be so
concentrated coming out your body wants
to get rid of as fast as possible yeah
this is the mushroom that's on the cover
of the John Marco Allegro book the
sacred mud okay across that's that much
well what would be the evolutionary
advantage of a reindeer eating this they
trip though feels good but they're gonna
be vulnerable ooh I don't think so some
animals and including like Lube like
Vikings they would trip and then go into
war and they thought it'd help actually
gave them an advantage they would call
them berserkers like because they're not
gonna be feeling pain and they're not
gonna be fearing death they're not gonna
be fearing death and they're going to be
well first of all war was such a part of
life it was so normal and so constant it
was a constant and they wanted in some
ways it would be heightened or prepared
for it's whether they were drunk which a
lot of tribes would just get drunk and
then going to war or whether they cuz
they would just be able to and endure
and be willing to do things that maybe
they wouldn't be able to do or be
willing to do if they weren't drunk
maybe they would anticipate you know the
the potential dangers of combat and
they'd freak out when they drunk about
[ __ ] and just run in and will they
would do that with mushrooms too I just
remembered this is foothill antiques for
the mammoth tooth they're great stuff
it's a guy
live anymore that where to buy them all
well he's got four night also I got from
him Dino for night what is that you know
about for date no this is such a cool
thing so all the car companies all the
car companies used to use spray paint or
like manually for the different cars
right so over the years you'd have
layers of this paint and it became
basically an artificial mineral so when
you take a cross-section it looks like
here give me that better why not give
you them a nice plant so yeah for tight
right you have these car companies car
car plants so they're spray painting the
Ford truck black the next year it's red
the next year it's green over time the
painting cute accumulates and you can
use that cross section to make really
cool things Wow yeah look up Freud I
Jamie looks really really put the
behavioral raining yellow oh that's real
yeah that's from a car that's what a car
plant cuz look every year it's a
different color it's a really cool
substance I got a couple of four-day
pens warthog tusks that's crazy
wooden one from the DMZ yeah Wow
is that amazing I was really cool yeah I
never heard of that before
and so one more time they're taking it
out of like a Ford plant or a Corvette
or whatever every one of Corvette went
forward and over the years you know
they'd ship it away from the walls
mm-hmm and they have a block of it there
you go give that thick yeah Wow and you
can do whatever you want with it
including makeup attorneys and [ __ ]
cool right that's like a cool form of a
fossil or something or it's like an
industrial fossil yeah
this is cool cuz I got the layer it
select tree rings almost and so you have
a pen made out of that I've got two oh
you lucky devil yeah you send me one for
free so how do people know that you're
you're into pens oh so I do something
called spike funding right so what
happens on Twitter is every so often
some [ __ ] will come for me and I'll be
like it would be a shame if people send
me money to waste on things I don't want
just despite you and I put up Michael
mass comm contribute and I go oh I will
post receipts and people send me cash
and they say this has to be wasted so I
buy I don't need seven pens
I don't need eight shaving brushes I
don't need a signed copy of Langston
Hughes's book I got them
and this is all because of a [ __ ] yeah
sons after you on Twitter and I'm like
okay people are gonna sit and then they
go oh you know you're a snake oil
salesman I'm like no no no one's getting
anything out of this except for spite in
you I don't really need these things
I'll let that make you a snake oil sales
cause they're like oh you're conning
these people out of money they're like
no no it's all understood this is total
waste of money just to [ __ ] with you
well they definitely don't know what
snake oil is then ya know what why are
you engaging with people on Twitter
you're a smart guy because it's fun you
enjoy it it's hilarious it's my biggest
activity really in clowning idiots
that's your number one thing it's - I'm
really fun with it and I'm really good
with it I've started doing a little bit
of psyops on Twitter too so yeah so like
for example what I've been doing is a
lot of these people these candidates
they're like press secretary will have
fewer followers than me
right so I'll say something like hey
there was an article in The New York
Times today about your candidate how
freaked out is the campaign and how much
is this a reflection on you not being
able to do your job correctly because
you know in that article hits the new
york times during the campaign you're in
the bunker you're freaking out what does
this mean so two halves and if someone's
like [ __ ] you they're giving like no
[ __ ] you so you do this even if there's
not a real story well if there's a story
oh because you know they're in full
panic okay so when they're in full panic
then you attack yeah for fun and because
they're bad people often which ones are
bad Jeremy Corbyn and camel Harris those
are the two I thought were the worst
other than that I don't think anyone's a
bad person who's the Corbin guy again
what he he's the court wouldn't in labor
right what's the name again Jeremy
Corbyn yeah what does he do he was the
head of the Labour Party in the UK
that's right okay just had the biggest
disaster election since 1935 worst like
that's right he he my favorite thing he
did was he said his pronouns
oh yeah said my pronouns are he/him yeah
yeah yeah I did this video my name is
Jamie Corbin Jeremy Corbyn yeah whatever
the [ __ ] it is Elizabeth Warren has her
pronouns on her pink on Twitter house
yeah well this is signalling that you're
part of the tribe yes yeah you're
willing to believe in nonsense that
[ __ ] is 150 years old she knows what
her [ __ ] pronouns are
mum and mummy come on with this nonsense
your pronouns are what's your name is it
Elizabeth
yet you're late you're a lady right come
on I know in her defense - in her
defense Warren is a man's name so it's
not fair oh yeah it's so stupid it's so
stupid yeah uh what do you know what
your name reek raucous No
so Jenna Murray crock I had her on my
it's just all so funny how could I'm not
saying you're concerned how
conservatives react to this stuff she
was as mikowski like the world champion
power lifter right thousand pound squat
something crazy no my mom comes out as
trans or gender fluid whatever janae and
people I don't my show people freaking
out all a lot competing as a Mack what
I'm like everyone no no as Matt yeah
before and after he was a world record
holder he competed as a man and now
they're like well if he compete as a man
I got a world record now he wants to be
chick I don't know what to do about this
and they don't know how to react what's
happening there she's an amazing there's
a transgender power lifter janae Marie
Kroc shares unbelievable of course it's
unbelievable look at look at that lady's
arms I mean now I'm G correct and call
her a lady she's toned down she's lost
weight what there's a document on her
own transformer what's happening there
and so she competes as a woman no no she
could be a man at years ago there's a
lift named after her this took four
people open it lifts name enough then
the Arnold press you got the Pendley row
deadlifts after Kevin deadlift and croc
Rose after Matt dead Liv was named after
a guy as a joke picture again
transgender lifter janae Murray look at
that what is happening here compete for
IFBB Pro that's bodybuilder Jessica
meeting as a male Jesus I'm so confused
but then again Eddie Izzard was on here
and Eddie has been like the most open
transgender person forever and he still
calls himself
okay and he likes women yeah she dates
women okay
she's just likes [ __ ] them with
makeup on [ __ ] I I don't know how she
[ __ ] that's the thing what kind of
chaos she's a really nice person
this is Kali Yuga I thought this is I
had her opening jars in my show for me
oh I bet she could do more than that
it's weird to say she because she's
still clearly on male hormones yeah
clearly should we discuss that on the
air oh she does I think she took
estrogen pee did both and it was kind of
hard to get the balance right because
you have she still does both I do I'm
not sure which is certainly more
bothered if she's competing his male
she's obviously running tests at huh yes
look at the size of her and that's
smaller she he dick or no dick so what
are we doing here here's the thing
here's the thing here's what I think if
you are setting a world record in
powerlifting I will call you whatever
you want and I will respect you okay
you don't think that's a major
accomplishment sure I don't care if you
want to be a grower yeah I'm cool with
it but it's just hilarious
still there okay because there's a sign
of the chaos of this moment in history I
do love the chaos I know and tricksters
historically have been gender fluid loci
and all these figures that are clear
coyote they always switch genders and
yes that's a good point so maybe it's a
sign of the chaos of our age that
there's more transgenderism cordial
intercept do you think there is or do
you think people are just talking about
it more I think it's there's so many
pluses and minuses and and it's it's
such a weird loaded situation and I
don't other thing is if you are a guy
who has feminine qualities that doesn't
make you non-binary just like if you're
like a tomboy yeah you're not you're not
not by course yeah yeah of course there
I mean there there's butch women yeah
we're really they don't sound good yeah
there's always been an effeminate men
yeah it doesn't mean you're an but
that's also a thing that really makes
some gay activist angry because they're
like if you leave children alone that
have these feelings there's a large
percentage of them they become
gay men and you're almost saying there's
something wrong with being a gay man you
have to become a woman like it's almost
an anti-gay stance well do you know that
with the will interfere the world chant
the world capital of sex change is
Tehran do you know what yes I do know
about this I'll tell the story though
you know why they have to do right
because they regard homosexuality is to
pray yes but if you want to become a
woman and have sex with men that's fine
yes so they make them basically have
these sex changes yeah a lot of them
just don't really totally go all the way
through with it because they don't think
of themselves as women they're like I
want to suck a dick but I don't have a
[ __ ] so they pretend to be a woman but
they don't really get the operation yeah
but they're trying to force a lot of men
to get in operates it's a [ __ ] up
place like in the Middle East what do
you think about this whole you you're
more informed than me about
international issues I mean for Christ's
sakes you went to North Korea I've never
been Snell's day it's the new at Milan
that's what I heard
what do you think about all this crazy
[ __ ] that's going on right now with Iran
I have a great book idea and it's such a
great book idea I'm gonna just drop it
here in the hopes that if I don't ever
do what someone does it and give it away
yeah I'm gonna give it away I hope
somebody does this a lot of people do at
the same time to each other or no you
cannot ID a [ __ ] or some publisher
wants to contact my agent just give me a
deal on the spot I'll do it okay blood
you want to do it I'll do it
so what's not tell anybody well I don't
want to do the proposal so if they want
to just make me an offer
good blood lust the media's love affair
with war for a hundred years
spanish-american war Willie Randolph
Hearst right the sinking of the
Lusitania we were taught about yellow
journalism when we're kids back up you
know the eight 1903 a ba ba ba ba bla
but now it's not
they love war they can't get enough for
Trump is only presidential when he's
bombing Syria they just are desperate to
push the war drums and what I love about
again Tulsi is she's served and she's
like war we have to start seeing war as
a last resort instead of a first
priority in a first response and I don't
know what's going to happen as a
consequence of Iran this guy is most
people know sulemani was a huge deal
like he was really revered in Iran and
very hated by people elsewhere but Trump
also started killing other people and
like Yemen he took somebody
in some other countries go they're going
on a killing spree so it's I don't think
this is gonna be World War three at all
because Iran knows they can't win and
I'm sure right now but you know they're
doing exercise right now with Russia and
China sure let them do it sure exit we
do exercise with South Korea every year
and North Korea freaks out and it's like
okay we're just it's just flexing your
muscles right until I think very
strongly we're never gonna be privy to
this that there's a lot of stuff going
on behind the scenes that we don't know
that people are talking and like what's
going to happen I'm sure well there must
be but the idea that he was willing to
just do that and that he even has the
call that he can make the call like
there's here several options sir
right which one you want to do only
could that guard killed well I think
it's amazing that we've gotten to the
point where you're blowing up a wedding
right and you're killing a lot of people
and you're killing just him and one
other person yeah they only killed two
people
that like the precision of that is
something that's got to be scary to the
Iranians it should be scared us yeah
scary to everybody cuz it's not like
that can't come over it here Oh what do
you mean that kind of technology can't
be used against Americans by another
country well I certainly could frankly
if they're gonna be terrorists I'd
rather they taking out one person than
3,000 no no for sure I'm just saying the
precision of it
oh yeah fact that they have that kind of
ability just just the drone ability in
general there's the ability to wage war
in countries we don't even occupy like
the all the different drone attacks in
Yemen oh yeah really sketchy in terms of
like the legality of it like what it's
not really a military strike but it's
definitely a military strike I mean I
think we've been playing fast and loose
with rules of war for a long time and I
think everyone knows this is nothing
particularly insightful that war and the
rules of war written by the powerful
people I remember when people were
talking about how much of a war monger
Obama was because drone strikes went up
considerably from Obama from George Bush
to Obama and I'm like yeah you know what
else went up drone technology yeah
nothing to do with him they're just
getting better at bombing people you
know how to do it better and this is
something I've argued people and wonder
about when you become prêt like Obama
was very anti-war through his
campaign he was a big lefty he went to
all the Ivy League schools bubble all
right we know his culture that he came
from he gets in the white house he's
drone bombing everybody what do you
think that is the question I have is do
you think and I'll get my Alex Jones hat
on do you think that they sit you down
when you're president and they're like
alright here's what you can be in charge
of but here's how it's going to be
internationally and I wouldn't be
surprised if that's the way it happens I
think there's no way until you get into
office you ever really understand what
information what you know what plans
that they can reveal that terrorists
have what you know what kind of I mean
there's there's got to be some kind of
intelligence they receive that probably
scares the [ __ ] out of them oh yeah when
you stop and think about how many
nuclear bombs there are how many radical
terrorists there are how many different
sects how many people fight over each
other how here's here's some photographs
of a crime scene that we found that Isis
be had all these hell yeah it's like
this is all real stuff that you they
could show you and they go look we have
done our very best to keep everybody
safe but there's only one way to keep
doing this
we got a drone bomb yeah and I can't
thrown away I know that many years ago
and I'm not supposed to know this but
I'll be all there was a nail bomb in
Grand Central that they caught in the no
one talked about it no one talked about
it
who found the nail bomb the the
authorities the right people and they
took care of it and nothing happened but
think how many soft targets there are no
it overseas I mean that's what captain
nail bomb down must have been what at
the time like Qaeda I'm guessing I don't
know I don't have any further
information I'm gonna question you
further if you could question me all you
want I even have my can waterboard I'll
tell me the story again so there's this
place Grand Central where the sky is
been a Grand Central of course and then
into the spot where the bomb was left
probably how do you know where the ball
is live I don't know
but ever since I've been throughout
Grand Central i okay yeah okay tell me
the story again from the beginning this
is how they do it and they eventually oh
yeah yeah yeah now tell the same story
over no no you hadn't [ __ ] to it you
probably nervous worried about dying
it's like scat you know you the words
trying to change a little over time yeah
yeah but you just lie you know if your
guy left a bomb Grand Central Station
they just keep getting you to tell that
story over no exhausted and then they
twist it around just a little bit just a
little bit for you and then you agree
with their twist and they had a little
more it was like Stalin's right-hand man
various said find me the Med and I'll
find you the crime that's a real scary
thing about cross-examining people like
and just examining it just is just
interrogating people
I am NOT saying that cops do this all
the time that they do get people to
believe they did something wrong but you
can get some that believe they did
something wrong especially if someone's
like limited intellectually oh yeah you
can talk your way into an arrest but you
can't talk your way out of one right and
it's it's an if they want you there's a
there's an old line that a conservative
is a liberal who's been mugged and a
liberal as a conservative who's been
arrested because when you get in that
government's clutches you're gonna be
very glad that there's the ACLU and all
these Miranda rights people who are like
looking out for the weak and won it as
hard as possible for you get arrested
and go to jail because it's think about
this it's like being audited is it ever
gonna be nice it's never gonna be nice
never gonna mean so getting arrested
it's not going to be oh we're sorry we
bothered you mr. Smith no no no no no
yeah we're not your friendly country IRS
right
oh we're friendly we're just a country
store IRS yeah hey I'm sure there's some
sort of miscommunication hey you want to
make sure this all works out well for
everybody's love the Uyghurs a box of
cookies I saw some meme where they're
like here's how the IRS works there's a
number you owe they know that number
they won't tell you the number you have
to figure out the number and if the
number you pay isn't the number that
they have they're gonna get you in
trouble yeah it's like you have to read
their game yeah they're just trying to
prosecute as many people as they can yes
it's like people that pull people over
speeding like you got to prove that you
didn't get pulled over Sweden I was
pulled up when I might lyft driver at
the airport was just paused I threw in
my trunk got in the car within this five
seconds the cop was writing him a ticket
and I paid for half the ticket in the
tip and I couldn't believe it and I'm
standing and the guy's like oh you know
he's just got it's just doing his job I
go well you've got a shitty job like
what kind of person are you
that this is what you do writing a 75
buck ticket for someone who's like a
lyft driver no and he's not even
blocking traffic he's not stopping
anywhere you're a horrible human being
well they have quotas that's no problem
quotas are gross I've talked to cops and
they have like a certain number of
tickets that they have to write every
month or they're gonna get in trouble
yes and it put your protect and serve
what kind of servant is telling me to
pay them like money I don't want it's an
officer the piece stealing money yes as
hard as how they keep the piece yeah
yeah he'd be scared yeah don't money
don't get Russians start on the cops
it's not gonna end well
what do you think about all the Hong
Kong [ __ ] then I am so hopeful for the
people of Hong Kong and I talked about
in my show nightshade constantly my hope
is it reminds me of Paul in 1989 right
in Poland 1989 you had this big labor
movement solidarity they weren't
conservatives they were lefties they
were labor and they were like look the
Constitution says we have democratic
elections and you have them there's only
one candidate let's have elections let's
have elections and the cotton Margaret
Thatcher came there supported them she
was loved in the Eastern Bloc so the
Polish Communist Party sat down and
they're like alright let's have these
elections and then there were some that
well what if we win all the elections
because they ask the people who you're
going to vote for all the Communists the
commies communists the elections happen
the labor solidarity wins every seat
except one and the question is are they
going to honor this what are they going
to wave it away they honored it and that
was the beginning of the end of the
Soviet Union I don't think you could
have Tiananmen Square today because
Tiananmen Square was before smartphone's
Tiananmen Square was before the Internet
there's no footage tank man wasn't
killed he was pulled away Hong Kong
we're seeing the footage and when you
see kids getting beaten and tear gassed
you don't need to speak any language to
look at and be like something's not
right here and decide with the people
who are getting beaten this is a very
Martin Luther King thing like even the
racists were like I don't want these
people to have dogs attacking them in
water hoses this is outrageous mmm yeah
so I'm very very hopeful this is going
to work positively to start the end of
the you know evil Chinese
dictatorship I hope you're right I hope
you're right and that would also work
towards liberating North Korea which is
obviously my pet issue do you think that
it's possible for China to ever turn it
around though
forget about Hong Kong but mainland
China turn what around we turn what
around in terms of their whole
dictatorship oh yeah Russia the Soviet
Union did it but did they yes did they
yeah you a puppet of Putin as well he's
my uncle
I mean it kind of did it but they're
kind of a dictatorship right now you can
you can get a passport you're not gonna
get your organs harvested who got a
passport who Roy Jones jr. is that Roy
Jones jr. who's that who the [ __ ] are
you man I'm a piece of [ __ ] who was
never was snatched dude Roy Jones jr. is
one of the greatest boxers of all time
okay he won the super middleweight
championship went up to the light
heavyweight and heavyweight okay he beat
John Ruiz to win the heavyweight
championship a guy who fought at 168
pounds okay he's a beast
okay sure he's one of the greatest of
all time and he also has a Russian
passport okay
okay that's awesome but the point is
people can leave Russia people can't
leave China and now they're going in a
bad direction with North Korea
instituting their social credit system
to control internal migration which is
really really bad what do you think
about people being able to go back and
forth like like what do you think about
travel back and forth from Russia into
the United States I mean they must be
like watching every single thing you do
I don't think it's as pervasive listen
you know what they're watching
everything we do here come on what do
you thing about Snowden being over there
I think I think ed Snowden should be
allowed to walk free I think so too
I mean and and he is it's it's insane
that we drove him into the hands of the
Soviet Union and what he was exposing
was illegal activity
he was official Stalin in his wildest
dreams and his KGB never had that power
of surveillance like Ed Snowden revealed
that every single cell phone is being
hacked into aren't they recording
literally every call yeah I mean it's
it's and we just said we're like oh this
is fine tracking a
it's just the level of taqwa right the
privacy the level of surveillance that
this government is putting forward is
insane it is crazy and remember when
Obama ranted about is like it just
metadata no words yeah it's fine just
trust us
just metadata yeah we're just collecting
metadata and he's and swats Nonna's like
no no no I was reading people's emails
right yeah we all read emails and there
was some report I forgot her name like
they were delete she was on her computer
and you could see the file being deleted
right in front of her she she's a good
video with her camera yeah because she
was breaking this stuff of Karass listen
if 4chan can get into your that hacker
4chan can get into your computer they
can of course it and of course they do
I mean it's did you think about that
before you google things oh that ship
has sailed that that's oh that's gonna
be a problem
oh that's gonna be a problem oh no oh no
oh there's a no no that's another one
mmm you ever go to I sometimes I'll like
I'll wake up until night and go on Etsy
or Wikipedia and you wake up and you're
like oh yeah I forgot I was going down
that rabbit hole while I was in middle
of the night just like looking up random
things no I don't [ __ ] with my computer
at night oh really
yeah why is that cuz it's not good for
your brain okay you could go down brat
like I I like to wind down at the end of
the night I'll occasionally checking
email what time you go to bed depends if
I'm performing it's usually not until
midnight ish maybe later
usually later if it's on a Saturday
night like this Saturday night I had a
10:45 spot so I wasn't in it the show
runs too usually a little bit late I
don't think I went on to like 11 I was
off stage like 11:15 ish and hung out
with my friends so I didn't get out of
there till 1:00 I didn't get home till
2:00 that's pretty normal for the Comedy
Store and then I usually always right to
when I come home huh
yeah it's usually my favorite time to
write everybody in the house is asleep
I'm a little high you know pull out the
laptop start writing you seem like a guy
who uses windows correct yes use the
Droid phone correct
I used to do a tech support in Windows
so Microsoft Office so I use Windows for
writing a lot because they know those
lenovo's keyboards are superior for a
lab wait what is a guy so you wait what
does a guy who uses Windows mean what
does that mean what with you yeah oh
you're a contrarian in a lot of ways but
they're the most popular and thing uh
yeah but not amongst creatives or people
in show bells okay kind of both of those
sure that's fair okay you're fighting
the fighting the trend but you some of
the guy a guy even if it was better you
would use it just to tell everybody to
[ __ ] off um a little bit that that would
play into mime calculus you may have
ever thought about going Linux I don't
even know that is no no a Linux is not
really I know it's an operating system
but I don't I wouldn't know how to
convert to that I don't think it's that
hard anymore okay the kernels that they
have now you can sort of install them on
a regular Windows machine you might even
be able to dual boot okay can you do a
boot with a Linux machine rebooting my
computer's like the most scary part of
my day so I really don't like doing that
Lenovo's keyboards are so superior
that's why I write on Windows
keyboards like a little ThinkPad
keyboard is so superior to anything
Apple has the touch and if all of them
have like a Scout like a Halfmoon shape
of them so your fingers what would you
describe that as what do you mean those
little semicircle but you know the divot
on cave concave I guess yeah you know
where every finger goes and that's so
easy to type that it's less effort you
don't think about it as much it's far
superior I use less it's like a plastic
like it's carbon I have an x1 carbon so
everything is like it has a soft feel to
it it's more comfortable to type on like
people go for the Apple like industrial
look I have an Apple laptop you know I
have I have another one a new one there
sounds good
the typing experience are getting a
thought down onto a word file right you
can do that better with a better
keyboard it's just that simple
and the fact that somehow another we've
gone for looks for this aesthetic this
like this sort of modern industrial
aluminum piece aesthetic over what's
more effective is very strange to me I
haven't liked keyboard looks like a
typewriter
because I'm a hipster I mean it's like
typewriter keys and it clacks
yeah Oh a round one I have one of those
it's a mechanical keyboard yeah yeah
yeah I have it
it looks like lights up so it's related
also you can feel yes its concave it's
just like what you're saying yeah that's
so big it's fun but this is like
everybody wants the thinnest possible
laptop see these like real short travel
yeah yeah and you don't know when you're
typing yeah it's not good it's like it
did everybody forget what a [ __ ]
keyboards for it's like are you such a
[ __ ] you can't even carry something
that's a half an inch thicker the [ __ ]
out of here man
this is nonsense like you're making
things thin for no reason like the looks
even coud we got thin and it is omim the
future yeah you're in the future we
can't type the [ __ ] out here let's go
back in the past you write something
down it's memorable
I'm back in the past I'm on my
typewriter for you and I love it
it's fun at night yeah yeah yeah I have
a mechanical keyboard it's my desktop
and it sounds good right it's actually
that's kind of like I feel like I'm
producing yes but it's just so easy to
know where the keys right there's no
mistakes like I had one of those 15 inch
retina Macs and the hood right on it's
like geez everything's flat there's a
really sure how family meter of key
travel so it's like click click click
click you make so many typos right I
make literally half a typos on a Lenovo
key I love my keyboard it's it's awesome
and I enjoy it do you run virus scans
and all kinds of [ __ ] and do you cover
your webcam with tape when you're beaten
off I I should start doing that I do run
virus scans I do not cover my webcam
with tape when I wonder some [ __ ]
fork and rolls in there let them let
them watch maybe they get an alert
whenever you porn gets pulled up in your
brows like didn't anything and they run
they're in there their parents house the
mom and dad are screaming each other
drunken slurs and they hear things
excuse me Michael Mouse's jerking off
trying to go and they run down the
basement bolt the door shut they're
gonna see quite a show imagine imagine
if they found a guy dead because he was
so excited to beat off watching you beat
off that he tripped falling down the
stairs and broke his neck have pants
half down
and and the cops break in and find out
what the [ __ ] going on and it's you
jerking off on a webcam this guy's dead
with his neck snaps at the bottom of the
stairs his pants half down well given
how many people jerk off to watching me
jerk off statistically that's gonna
happen at some point yeah that's what
I'm saying would you be excited yes
would you yeah that's awesome
I'd like that guy went out with a bang
yeah like might come kill him for sure
these people right now looking through
like perverts
looking through somehow or another
getting through a webcam and watching
someone oh of course
for sure of course and especially people
work for the government they talked
about I thought this was exposed
fascinating though they can do that it's
listen if you ever window into my life
though it's the opposite of fascinating
I assure you is really I'm one I'm about
five minutes away from being Terri
Schiavo what is this employees yeah
Rosen's ring I've been spying on Costas
videos are on Christmas for they're like
people were just getting on their
cameras talking to the kids like hey I'm
saying I go tell your parents that this
there's lots of them this is there so
much [ __ ] oh yeah I've heard that that
they were actually talking to people
through the device and that one guy was
terrorizing some woman who's like like
telling her was gonna kill her through
the device oh my god back that's a crime
yeah yeah yeah Captain Obvious Jesus
Christ I got it upgraded obvious just my
friend really bad there's something
called like the annoying thing I forgot
it's called and you said it and it goes
and it goes off at random times so I put
it under her bed and I forgot and then
the next morning I get a text that just
goes idiot like oh yeah she's like
Millau you know man you're an idiot cuz
you terrified me hey do you worry about
apps like Android apps being corrupted
like they apparently don't have a
stringent a testing I don't have that
many apps and I'm much more of a desktop
person I'm not on my phone that much
because I'm like a recluse are you still
a recluse why don't you get out do what
outside is scary I mean meet people I
don't ever meet anyone and I don't know
weird
go to meet people oh dude this sounds
like a Christmas movie for another
there's gonna be eight days or seven
days we fail yeah and then the eighth
day yeah let's get out and we're on boy
I don't you really don't you don't go
out I don't know
no and it's it's kind of a fort I also
don't get along with most people I'm not
for that I don't believe that because
you're easy to get along with that's
confusing to me but they're not easy to
get along with I think a lot of people
are basic as hell and they don't bring
anything to the conversation there's a
lot of that yeah yeah you got to find
better people to hang out with you know
how you do that you go outside I just
bro I have a good crew so if so listen
I'll tell you this my friend Matt the
one who was molested we had friends
giving and I said Matt you have a unique
opportunity to make this the most
awkward Thanksgiving in history these
people all like you they're they're your
friends sit down and tell them that this
happened and he's like I can't do it I
go okay how about this I'll do it if I
do it against her what if I do it
against her will I wouldn't really be
wrong given this story he's like dude
and I didn't do it but it would have
been funny a small amount of time would
have been funny and then he would have
just deal with the weight of all these
people which is also funny
maybe she stay as a recluse I think
you're doing good
maybe one of the only dudes is mastered
it the Unabomber it's your calling yeah
you'll never get around other humans do
you know what happened in the Unabomber
do you know how that happened the
brother yeah with it's because he was a
pedantic oh yeah it was that but it was
also the Unabomber himself Ted Kaczynski
be a part of the Harvard LSD studies was
he yeah they cooked his brain Wow
yeah there's a documentary about it
called the net someone wrote a great
tweet where they go plot twist Greta
Thunderbird grows up to become the
Unabomber in a Redemption arc I'm like
that is hilarious it was a very violent
environmentalist a very bright man he's
a professor at Berkeley so he went to
school at Harvard they put him in the
Harvard LSD studies that cooked his
[ __ ] dome and then he disappeared
went to Berkeley inva worked as a
professor
to earn enough money so you could buy a
cabin implement his plan to kill
everybody who was involved in technology
so he'd stop this takeover of the human
race which probably is true yeah
john waters the director he has a
replica of the Unabomber his cabin as a
room in his house is that great I love
that
who's got the real cabin oh that's a
good question it was at a museum I think
that actually just closed so I don't
know where no no no there was a museum
called the museum and oh yeah yeah you
know I think it's just close yeah they
couldn't traveling exhibit but they took
the whole cabin and reconstructed it I
believe I've seen pictures over here you
need to find a well that's really cool I
need to find an I love stuff like that I
do too I did an article years ago about
all these relics like where's Monica
Lewinsky's dress and like she's got it
hidden somewhere she she does yeah I
daughter could that people did
researched she still has it oh my god
what a nightmare for poor bill you get
your dick sucked in 94 and this lady's
still carrying that just stained dress
like Jesus Christ lady let it go he's
probably not well she's probably thrown
it away by now no no bill never
never listen
oh wow wow I thought that was a replica
I mean that says it was it and it closed
huh last week yeah I don't know where
it's at wow that is it they closed last
week I missed it by a week [ __ ] that
could have been out here bro
we could have that probably be an
expensive buy probably like me and
Marilyn Manson Oh mothers to each other
I guess we're just gonna have to nail
some of the bum he would probably buy it
whoo Benson yeah manifesto that's the
original
holy crap that's dark everyone tells me
to read it I haven't read it but they
said it's very smart I read parts of it
that's one of the things that's
disturbing is just like well thought out
and also the argument is sound
technology will inevitably lead to
better technology which inevitably leads
to artificial intelligence which is
inevitably gonna take over the world
well there's a whole singularity thing
right what's the Ray Kurzweil Kurzweil
and I don't know I haven't checked in
years but I don't know if we're on track
with what he predicted I think we're
supposed to be further along because
remember in the 50s we're gonna be
flying cars and there's no flying cars
yeah he's a 2045 guy and what he says is
that the exponential increase of
technology if you follow it right the
prediction is somewhere in the
neighborhood of 2045 they'll achieve
this singularity yeah but I think
they're also finding that there actually
is somewhat asymptotic and it does at a
certain point you are having like
physical limitations to increasing the
speed and it's not gonna be that easy
yeah well then quantum supremacy comes
along you know they trying to change the
name of quantum supremacy because it
confuses people with white supremacy and
we really shouldn't support that so we
need to change quantum supremacy they
also they had was an IBM or whatever had
the quantum computer and the other
people like this isn't really quantum
because of blah blah blah blah mmm this
was a big controversy just in last month
those quantum people I found its new
location after the Montana Historical
Society tried to get it it now exists at
this fun place the FBI experienced Jesus
they own it so there's like a
interdivisional cooperation FBI
that's the propaganda house Wow so they
wanted to get money so he was in Montana
when he was blown above desert someone
tried to buy that land I guess or was
for sale at one time that whoever runs
this museum tried to get a hold of it
and if the FBI said we're gonna keep it
yeah I can understand why they would
want to right of course yeah Wow very
valuable people probably will go to the
FBI Museum specifically just to see that
cabin no one wants to go to the FBI
Museum otherwise would you go to the FBI
museum no his brother his brother
suspect that he was doing it oh you know
I'm for the the manifesto or did he read
the manifesto in that well because the
Unabomber as a kid was always annoyed by
people saying you could have your cake
and eat it too because he's like no no
no it's you can eat your cake and have
it too and the Unabomber used that
phrase air quotes correctly and the
guy's like that's my brother and that's
how they figured it out because he was
being a pedantic dick yeah so everyone
who's correcting people and spelling on
Twitter shut up and relax oh that's
crazy I thought he just recognized the
style of right and no I I mean I double
check me but I'm 90% sure this is
correct you're saying that your cake and
have it too it's actually ringing a bell
yeah god damn it it's it's imagine like
that if he was a normal guy and they
just filled them up with acid and they
made him say oh my god technology's
gonna take over and he just started his
his calling life is to kill the people
they're advancing technology with bombs
when you're that smart you're already
kind of tripping because regular people
don't seem like the same thing as you do
right and maybe a little schizophrenic
and then they fill him up with a [ __ ]
half a gallon of acid like how much did
they give him do you know who knows they
were experimenting with people I'm sure
it's not gonna be small doses you know
what operation midnight climax is now
one of my favorite [ __ ] up
CIA experiments they ever did they went
to brothels and they set up a brothel
with all these prostitutes and these
John's and they dosed all the guys and
use hidden cameras and you know because
the guys couldn't talk about it because
like what happened
arrey somebody gave me a Mickey they
slipped me a Mickey and I had a bad time
where this happened Harry oh I don't
know I guess I was at the diner or
something you can't say I went to the
whorehouse try to get my dick sucked and
they gave me acid these [ __ ] you
can't say that and we've been trained
since kindergarten that if someone says
the CIA has experimented on regular
people they will tell you and admitted
it they will tell you with a straight
face that that's the conspiracy theory
yeah they will just use that word and
stop thinking and we've been trained for
decades and it's a great a minute we've
been hearing three years that there was
a conspiracy between Trump and the Putin
administration that's a conspiracy
whether it's true or not
Epstein was a conspiracy he was
conspiring with a lot of people yeah
Weinstein Bill Cosby these are all
conspiracies that are widely known but
if you as soon as you hear that term
like racist mm up conversations over I
didn't hear anything else that's amazing
oh you believe in conspiracy theories oh
yeah
what 9/11 didn't happen come on yeah
well I laugh we were talking in the last
podcast about Epstein and we watched we
looked at some of the autopsy photos and
looked at some of the the the accounts
especially particularly dr. Michael
Baden the guy from the HBO autopsy show
murdered I got a question
why is there no perp walk photos why is
there no photos him in court why is
there no photos him getting off the
plane I have no answer but isn't that
weird every other person is arrested you
see the perp walk yeah including El
Chapo including El Chapo including
Harvey Weinstein literally everybody
you've got footage that could they the
media knows where to wait right
why is there no footage of what the [ __ ]
I don't have an answer but it's and the
thing is to even say this doesn't this
is weird conspiracy theory no literally
tell me what what I'm missing
well here's where it gets even weirder
you know that he was like visited while
he was in jail by women and like you
you'd have his assistant come to visit
him in jail I did not know oh yeah 16
hours a day he'd get to hang out in the
like Wow lawyer a special room where
they would buy out all of the pot
machines and snacks all of them and he's
just good to sit in there and hang out
Wow
16 hours a day
sis and they were they were somehow
another either negotiating with him or
they were placating him or they were
trying to resolve this issue peacefully
they were trying to figure out a way
like this guy knew too many people and
wasn't talking and while he wasn't
talking they were trying to like
desperately get to him I would assume
and stop him from potentially talking
and then while the prosecutors closing
in and while they're making this
airtight case and the only way for him
to make anything more lenient is to
start saying yeah she's jealous
really supposedly remember all those
files that he had with all the people
where'd they go no one's asked Jamie's
gone I've got him no I mean someone FBI
to your PD but why we're not hearing
anything about it he's got names of many
people not just names but video today
yeah dudes [ __ ] kids it's just this
is classic conspiracy theory proven true
it's a class we all saw it coming but
this is a classic conspiracy theory that
there's a guy who works for intelligence
agency who compromises wealthy and
famous and even intellectuals famous
people and then takes these people and
brings them to an island where he brings
in a bunch of girls that are underage
and they all [ __ ] and then he films it
he'd be like what are you even talking
about right but this is all that's real
what about the fact that he's number two
she's like in Israel or something isn't
she she's not Brazil okay yeah she's not
arrested how's that happening how was
Prince Philip not arrested yeah how was
she yeah like how they not whacked her
right well they had it's not right but
that part of the deal he made the first
time was that he had I think at least
four if not more co-conspirators that
are not allowed to be or that's part of
the deal is that they can't be arrested
how is he in a position to make deals
I'm not arguing through doesn't make
sense doesn't what leverage do you have
you're like the one the world's biggest
pedophile ring and it's like all right
you can't arrest my people though oh
okay that's fair mr. Ripstein sir we
promise not to kill you in jail I think
maybe there's a concern that if maybe
she ELISA if I was gonna be the
writes the script I would say there's a
dead switch yes and then if she dies
this [ __ ] gets out and she says listen
the moment I die all this [ __ ] gets
published epstein she's undergone scene
like they're protecting her ex Special
Forces guard why is it that pictures of
Michael Jackson is that like a
pedophiles probably leaving Neverland I
guess yeah I was different why they put
that story there they're thinking the
person watching this is a pedophile
really into pedophilia very strange dude
Maxwell faces credible death threats and
is being guarded by formas you you would
see these heels and safe houses in the
American Midwest [ __ ] in a while
yeah Shake Shack good lord
I mean all she has to do is Dyer hair
people Midwest don't even read they have
no idea that she's there did you write
I'm all right they're not paying
attention
did you see the Prince Philip interview
yes oh my god strange oh I loved it so
strange he seems a little Specter me am
I wrong
something's not right there something's
wrong once you're watching this in your
land he's like oh yeah you know I cut
off contact with him they're like well
there was a dinner in August well I was
talking by then you were the guest of
honor oh well it was like what the [ __ ]
dude yeah yeah he seems like he's a
little detached from reality in some
sort of strange way yeah well your your
prince for that long you're not gonna be
able to begin with right there's no way
like he's you can't develop without
trials and tribulations and become and
come out normal especially when you're
not just a famous person but you're a
royal yeah like when they asked him
about hugging the girls I'm a royal we
don't as it were hug hug yeah the best
[ __ ] through a hole in the bathroom the
best part wouldn't fit the Kevin Spacey
stuff going on
doesn't seem directly related but it
doesn't seem unrelated in any way Calum
with no it is somewhat related because
this is one of those things where things
are open secrets and in Hollywood and
like everyone kind of knows everyone
knew that Kevin Spacey was a dick
grabber
yeah yeah and it's kind of like then
it's like Oh
conspiracy theories like you guys are
comfortable with this you [ __ ] well
that's a weird one right because that's
like we always heard of though the wild
artists that we're doing things that are
[ __ ] up but we kind of let them get
away with it because they were really
talented and there's no real proof and
what goddamn ad blocker you [ __ ] Jesus
financial financier Jeffrey Epstein once
flew Bill Clinton and Kevin Spacey to
Africa oh Jesus hey Clinton really likes
Russia that he want to [ __ ] the aids
monkey he's like I wanna be patients
here I think I could fix it yeah I got
that super Arkansas come inside that
monkey and start all over India I think
mushrooms grass on the floor dude he
went with that guy at least 26 as many
as 28 times and his plane well say hey I
just flew a couple times my friend
Jeffery yeah we're friends I had one ADA
Broderick on my show the one who had a
rape accusation against him and I went
in there hoping that she was lying he
raped her in the morning and it was like
half an hour like she he went with her
to her hotel room in Arkansas and it was
I thought was I could be like 9 o'clock
they had a few drinks no it's she's
supposed to meeting with him about
something
it's horrible what these people get away
with and I think Americans do you think
he physically killed her that's he did
her and then he know he bit her lip just
like a cat to keep her from yelling and
then when he left the last thing he says
there you better put some ice on that
and another woman who accused him of I
think was Kathleen Willey who accused
him of forcing herself on him he bit her
lip too and the two had never knew each
other before they independently had the
same thing that he does he bites her lip
so they don't scream or he just bites
dilip's because it's hot to get you know
whatever that's his thing it's the thing
that Americans don't get which they are
increasingly starting to get is that
people in power are often really
depraved and they will use their power
in sadistic ways and they get off on not
having consequences it's not just being
corrupt like oh I'm getting a kickback
for hiring my cousin it's so much worse
than that and they're starting to see it
now with like the amy robach thing who's
that she's that ABC News reporter the
footage leaked where she's just like we
have
the whole Epstein story yes Prince
Phillip we had Bill Clinton and the
lawyers killed it and she was just and
she was like pissed that she didn't get
the scoop but it's she's like I a
hundred percent think he was killed and
it's like yeah this is what they're like
when the cameras are off right um the
the Clinton thing is so [ __ ] weird
right because you have Hillary who was
this woman who was going to be the first
woman president yeah everyone was behind
her and we were all thinking that she
represents hope and change and all the
wonderful things that the progressives
want sure he's got this husband right
husbands right and when when they had
that debate and Trump brought those
women you have to sit out in front I was
like no he did oh yeah oh no he didn't
yeah and Melania was wearing a [ __ ] bow
was she yeah it's a certain type of not
she had a [ __ ] bow there's a special
kind of not called a [ __ ] bow yeah whoa
yeah yeah yeah so there's this a lot of
[ __ ] up [ __ ] in Jeff right now we're
tough it he was a good guy I supported
science play them dancing it up there's
Justine I say is that her is that
Melania Lane yes I was that Melania
yeah that's Melania thanks I'm pretty
sure oh and who's that in the back right
that looks like Lady die something's
lady died came back photographer she's
not dead she's hiding with Elvis she's
hiding with Epstein in Brazil or over
his got just awful awful people it's
just amazing that you could still whack
somebody as high-profile as Epstein
publicly in this day and age that you
could say oh the cameras didn't work
guards oh they weren't around within
hearing we just watched Salamone that's
different it innocent way it is anyway
it's not because these people will do
whatever they need to dmitry think that
these people are in control like when
we're watching this we would say that
the guards are in control in the prisons
in control and they've got this captive
and they're gonna bring them to the
justice system because the justice
system once it here is k sure they want
them to testify there's a lot of other
moving pieces a lot of players we're
very interested see what kind of
horrible crimes are committed by these
elites that you know and then also any
gets killed let's say they do it right
out in front of everybody's knows what
happened with Jack Ruby
well same thing it's just like hi this
is the most important person on earth
right now to keep safe hey you're not
doing it right
Jack Ruby just runs up and shoots him in
the gut yeah bang
lemur goes well yeah it's just like how
is how are you letting this happen yeah
even if all the conspiracy theories are
wrong how are you [ __ ] up so bad that
this is allowed to happen Yeah right
there bang I was like wow it was a
couple of days wasn't it after he shot
JFK it was barely over it there was no
time at all face well yes getting
murdered of course gonna hurt we should
probably get that that's what I look
like when I'm beating off by the way
that's the thing that people see that
face you know Jamie let's get that
picture converted into a giant metal
framed photo bunch of good ones like an
eight year and a half ago just one
mystery like out like a museum here man
look at Jack Ruby looks like a piece of
[ __ ] who's ever anybody looked like a
piece of [ __ ] oh well look at he looks
like sloth from the Goonies
oh oh you look so creepy look at me I
did what I had to do I did what I had to
do Jesus yeah why did why did he even
say that he did it I don't remember his
excuse it's not like the guy wasn't
gonna get the death penalty for killing
with effing president yeah but he was
gonna talk that was what they're really
worried about that Lee Harvey Oswald was
gonna talk and he's gonna give up
yeah but Ruby's not gonna say I shot him
cuz he's gonna talk you have a ruby
probably was under some sort of a you
know they probably owed money or they
were gonna kill him
no but he's gonna say some reason
publicly right he's not gonna say I did
this because that would money he never
did rat anybody out if that was the case
I mean he went to jail and I think he
died of cancer in jail okay they
probably shot him something was asleep
but it's just he's gonna have some
excuse to be like why he did it your mom
with cancer bug yeah look at the Koala
juice you know you can have a koala piss
on him and then next thing you know
you've got cancer yeah wonder how long
he lived I think he lived in jail for
like a decade that long when did Jack
Ruby die in jail he died in jail a
cancer I'm pretty sure canary embolism
January 3rd 1967 oh this is four years
that's not a real answer though
pulmonary and pies that right give
somebody where's that stroke I think
that's a straw
okay is it yeah embolism stroke yeah
then you can give somebody
oh yeah secondary to Bronco genetic
carcinoma which that is cancer yeah oh
so you get cancer they gave they doubled
up his throat just he probably had lung
cancer anybody everybody back then all
those morons were smoking it's a crazy
story though you know to this day until
that Zapruder film got released by
Geraldo Rivera of all people and
goddamnit
what's his name who brought it to hear
all the Rivera Dick Gregory Dick Gregory
the comedian okay
brought the Zapruder film to Geraldo
Rivera show more than ten years after
the assassination so I think was 12
years later I think was 75 and it brings
the there's a pruder film that shows the
head going back into the left and they
censored some of the frames at certain
points I know yeah TV
I know Zapruder didn't want a couple of
frames I was just when I won I woke up
one day recently and I saw that in
middle the night I was reaching about
there's a better film up and just read
about it know I wake up like oh yeah I
was reading about this at 5:00 in the
morning
did you ever read best evidence by David
liftin no it's that about is that about
JFK it's yeah it's all about the Warren
Commission report he was like this
really meticulous accountant and he was
hired to do something with the Warren
Commission report to go over it and he
decided to go over every aspect okay and
talked about all the different the
contradictions and all the things that
are wrong with it and it was his
conclusion by the end of the book that
President Kennedy was assassinated and
this is a conspiracy Wow wrote a book
called best evidence it's really good
it's it freaked me out that I [ __ ] up
once and read it before I went onstage
[Laughter]
and it was so freaked out my thing
killed Kennedy and this about Jack Ruby
it says that it took six months for them
to talk to him and he had to ask for
them to talk to him Wow no I did it no
we're good yeah you asked to be moved to
DC because he thought he was gonna be
killed where he was I guess in Texas or
hell they just lock that dude up and
said [ __ ] you yeah good luck they
probably they probably told him listen
Jack you do us a solid we're gonna take
care you in the in the pokey gonna give
you hoods I'm gonna shave your head
sneak you out the back door you're gonna
live in Argentina with Hitler yeah
nothing but whoís steaks sounds good rib
and just whiskey and have a good time
what do you say jeez just ran up on him
bang probably owed money probably had to
do something you know and you probably
they probably promised him the moon
listen to be an American Hero we'll get
you right out of this
you'll be insane temporary insanity Oh a
couple and just ran up we're know like I
was a patriot you know and I love JFK so
much blah blah blah okay yes no jury's
gonna convict him yes I like it
yeah so there's a lot of god there's so
much that I mean that term is just once
you realize that that term is used to
just dismiss oh yeah the entire schools
of thought and you realize just how
pervasive our training is since we're
kids yeah
well you mean there's so many [ __ ]
conspiracies that turn out to be true
Enron you know go across the board it's
a Vasko industry yes yes GRC merchants
of doubt' no what's that one it's a
great documentary that showed how the
same people that were literally the same
humans that used to go on TV and debate
the the idea that tobacco was
cancer-causing or that it was addictive
and they would go on these shows these
panel shows and they were hired by the
tobacco companies to go and do this and
they would go and just then it is not
addictive it's not addictive it doesn't
cause cancer and they would go on these
shows and just lie right and then that's
the that's the documentary well the same
people went later the same people we're
doing the exact same thing about climate
change how exact same thing yeah that's
the same human beings like these people
are merchants of doubt' like their job
someone hires them to go and do these
talk shows and talk over people and talk
really loud and have some very strong
points where you show these people that
they're being foolish you don't know
what you're doing do you ever do that is
that part of your job
like I just string what you said wait a
minute no no I'm saying what I did
if this if this the cigarette stuffs in
the 50s and climates in the 90s how are
they the same they were doing it long
past the 50s oh are you serious yeah
yeah they were doing it on these talk
shows they we just have a guy who would
claim to be an expert and this guy would
go on these talk shows and just say
things that are just patently untrue
it's great man you should see marches
it's it's one of those things if you sit
back and go what why would you hire the
same person right well it's a [ __ ]
because he's good at it because people
didn't know about the internet back then
right they didn't know it's right he's
gonna make a documentary like this they
didn't know that it would ever be
revealed this the same guy that was
going on all these other shows ten years
ago 15 years ago laughing at these
lawsuits saying look frankly it doesn't
cause cancer it's not addictive and then
the doctor via the other end who didn't
understand the [ __ ] the hustle yeah
yeah losing his [ __ ] it is I work for
the Harvard Medical Department course
you work for nobody you know then they
would have these merchants of doubt'
it's a it's a amazing documentary man
it's amazing
that's very distorted Michael Shermer it
isn't about the science it's about me
being consistent team members showing
the members of my tribe that you can
count on me
Michael Shermer skeptic Society he is my
fear on skeptics magazine or whatever
it's called yeah what is this thing I
mean that he's like one of the guys it
does it no I don't think that's it
really I think that's what this is
saying no these were these people that
are listing here then no let's roll up
yeah it must be contributors okay yeah
but that doesn't necessarily change it
guy he's not he's not doing that he's
probably explaining how they're doing it
right now they're exploiting skepticism
yeah that's yeah cuz he's a hundred
percent for I mean he hundred percent
believes a climate change and he's a
very science-based guy he's not right
about everything but you know he's also
one of those guys that believes the
official story always you have to beat
him in the head with it and then then
finally the headaches Magazine believes
the official story almost always and
then he comes up with some crazy
explanation why it works and then with
the Epstein woman was the first one he
said wait a minute
okay hold up hold seriously it was like
literally when I first times I've known
this guy for like eight years
so the first time and all the times that
I've known him that is it actually said
we didn't hold on the films missing but
this might be a conspiracy he literally
said this might be conspiracy look yeah
so blatant yes Michael Shermer who has
never met a conspiracy he doesn't want
to debunk he got to that one you went oh
this one's real they killed that [ __ ]
dude
yeah yeah or allowed him to kill himself
at the best
yeah but they even the the autopsy
results so like the way his neck broke
like in the way the bones in his face
broke like no like somebody choked that
guy yeah somebody choked that guy they
grabbed a hold of him when they
shattered his neck I I just think it's
so interesting how it's getting harder
and harder for them to keep a lid on
what stunts they're pulling off behind
the scenes yeah and that's why we're in
the World War 3 because with World War 3
there'll be much less scrutiny because
people be worried about contamination
and radiation and everybody that's in
power will being Dick Cheney's bunker
down deep into the bottom of the the
hole that they created somewhere around
the Pentagon I believe do you think that
we're gonna go to war over this worried
I'm legitimately worried that one of the
things was [ __ ] Trump made a tweet about
if they attack I'll you know attack them
with a disproportion yes and I was like
you can say that man because if you do
do that if you say that and then you do
that like was disproportionate man you
gotta just nuke someone you're gonna
launch missiles into the the capital
like what are you gonna do I don't think
if they attacked us that he would be in
a space not to attack disproportionately
back that's what I'm saying but even if
he hadn't tweeted that right I think
everyone be freaking out so bad
tweeted about it it makes you hard jesus
course threatening them on Twitter he's
basically threatening causing a war a
huge world war wait a minute I think if
you're killing their big general you're
already threatening them you definitely
doing this more than threatening but
already pulling triggered the attack in
the embassy and he can prove that guy as
a connection to six hundred Americans
600 plus American deaths because of I II
DS that they don't care and
Ron that's not gonna I know I know they
don't but at least it gives you some
sort of a motivation for taking this guy
out sure right I mean I've heard Dan
Crenshaw talk about it and some other
people make some explanations as to why
sure they needed to take this guy out
and why was a good thing maybe
apologists I don't know I don't know if
they're right or wrong I just [ __ ]
hate it I hate all of it you know I mean
I hate the fact that we get led into
these goddamn things that's the thing
yeah that this could happen that we
people could lose brothers and sisters
and friends and all of it
the most disturbing thing I've ever seen
there was this like a group of four
pictures of this little kid I remember
his name Timmy
and it's like the first one he's like it
needs a little camouflage like holding
up a photo of his dad then they made a
like stuffed animal with his dad's face
on it and then he's like holding up a
sign it's like I love you dad can't wait
to see you soon like the dad was dead
like 20 and they like show some support
for little Timmy I'm like this is
there's one of him kissing the dad's
gravestone and I'm like this is not good
like yeah we should support this kid but
it would be a lot better if he wasn't in
this position it's heartbreaking and
just seeing him cuddling with his dad's
doll it was it really messed with me
something fierce oh it's awful and we
need less of that we definitely know as
little as me as little of that as
possible it's just heartbreaking to say
and he's just so cute and proud there's
no crazy though that you mean you really
only can say as little as of that as we
can you can't really say we should have
no war because no one thinks right
because humans are conflict but and and
was like kill each other but that's
amazing yeah that as much as we know
like our base of knowledge that we can
extract information from is so giant our
ability to communicate with each other
is unprecedented we can translate things
in real time and still we got more is
inevitable yep someone wants to take
your stuff and I don't you know someone
else says I don't want you taking my
stuff this has been you know it's but
it's gotten a lot better
definitely a little better we get nuked
into the Stone Age
somewhere around March sure yeah just in
time for the primaries no I mean it used
to be it was considered appropriate that
if you beat someone in a war you kill
everyone yes and now it's like maybe we
don't need to like literally kill
everyone okay let's let's try that maybe
or maybe you kill this general and then
they kill some of your guys and then you
kill a bunch of people and they kill a
bunch of your people and they say if you
do that again we're gonna nuke you and
they should go ahead do it [ __ ]
and then you do and then Russia gets
involved then China gets involved then
Los Angeles gets vaporized so it has a
happy ending
Oh son of a [ __ ] well you'll be out
here with a [ __ ] crazy suit on and
there'd be no one here to listen to it
but crazy City made some sort of
radiation suit oh okay thank you my
clothes because I got an outfit ready
for when I'm unruly yeah you have a
[ __ ] apocalypse special tie
apocalypse the convocation a dark side
little atomic sighs I look like a new
wave singer look it's kind of amazing
that we haven't nuke to anybody since
1947 yeah that's amazing
yes all right was it 45 it was 45 Japan
yeah 45 yeah yeah so we haven't new to
anybody since 45 it's and no one else
has either that's what's amazing except
for Russia nuking themselves basically
which are no whoops yeah and then North
Korea didn't they do that didn't the
experiment in the mountains yes and the
monocle at Mountain but I don't think
anyone died yeah I mean look look not
gonna would that that's all that
happened this is wood you know yes it is
so I I mean I'm very hopeful about the
future of this country they possibly
iron things out with a rock how could
they possibly say to Iran hey [ __ ] up
[ __ ] I don't think he thinks he [ __ ]
up if Crenshaw has Craig if Crenshaw has
his back you know the explaining this I
think he's not gonna back peddle on this
Trump's not a back peddler anyway right
but do you think it's possible that they
could somehow another work this out yes
really yeah because if if Khrushchev and
JFK can work out the Cuban Missile
Crisis right JFK never sent a [ __ ]
drone to shoot down Khrushchev's
number-two guy sure but at the same time
if you're like look even were in a sense
the sanctions and how we've kind of
collapsed my understanding I'm not
expert Iran's currency is also a huge
deal and it has caused a lot of you know
suffering there so they didn't do
anything about that mmm true good point
at a certain point you know if you just
your dicks big enough the people just
have to be like the [ __ ] there's I think
that's real though I just feel like this
one is so public and demands a response
and I don't think they're not gonna
respond they could respond in some way
that's kind of like to say face now how
many right and right how many people do
you think are in the Iranian regime that
want change and that realizing that the
Iranian regime and their support of
certain aspects of terrorism and the
support of a lot of the stuff that
they're claiming this guy did including
the the IEDs right this is all
problematic because they brought this
upon them by their acts and their deeds
and then we need to change the
government like that's really what a
sophisticated intelligence society would
want they want they would want to figure
out how to infiltrate that thing that
organization and sow seeds of doubt and
like let everybody know hey do you love
your children I just made a giant
[ __ ] mistake I can't comment down I
can only look at it through the lens of
stuff actually I'm informed about which
is like North Korea and the Soviet Union
and what happens is these regimes the
people at the top aren't there because
they're smart or charismatic they're
there because they're loyal that's the
first thing they test for and everyone's
always looking after each other to kind
of like look this guy's gun soft and
they're getting rid of each other that
way that's the power plays going on over
there so if you have someone being like
oh maybe we shouldn't do terrorism all
of a sudden everyone's raising eyebrows
and being like this because if you're
going to advocate for that everyone's
got to be on the same page because
that's a big move to make right right so
if one guy's like a guy's movie this is
evil it's like okay now you're making us
look evil and I don't like having this
voice in the meeting so I think it's
going to be very hard to have some but
the thing is about this the strike
because it was so precise I'm sure
they're scared also that he would have
no problem killing them individually
that's the real fear so it's like oh if
I escalate this he might be coming for
me personally next or the people if
there's a you know a revolt it could be
like Gadhafi
being raped to death by like a
broomstick mmm and they don't want that
either it was a bayonet okay sorry okay
there's a little rougher that's even
worse
okay Wow remember that picture I know I
didn't look at it he stand there in
shock penis to have it on the [ __ ]
with with a knife oh my god yeah but you
said that that guy is gonna be the mount
you would Jima guy of the future you
know there's gonna be a guy just ramming
it right up Gaddafi's ass it's probably
in a mosque somewhere so yeah very
quickly you're gonna be wondering am i
next
and then you also wonder do I want to be
a martyr and like go out heroically well
you're making all good points but what
I'm worried about is some sort of an
attack on on some sort of a public place
a good Disneyland it'll be a lot easier
for them to your right or Disney Lenora
hitting Israel yeah like look we hate
them blah blah or a rock somewhere right
so who knows what I mean what they did
with the Iraq war with it when it was
Bush and Tony Blair they bombed the
train station in Spain and Spain
couldn't get out of the war fast enough
so it could be that they're going after
one of our allies to separate us you
know that might be a smart move to do
you go forward chess game there's so
many spots to hit you know what I mean
there's no way you can really it's like
a shell game there's only so many shells
Jesus Christ yeah the system make you
nervous and now but you're a psychopath
all right what do you mean aren't you
how am i psychopaths what a name calling
on this twenty20 Rogen's I'm kidding but
you you not nerve all in offer you
nothing you really 100 percent confident
and I'm not 100% confident at all are
you 60 percent confident yes I'm very
hopeful that's it yes so forty percent
might be the end of the world no end of
the world it's I don't think is on the
table at all no because I think what
happens is Russia and China and Britain
sit down with us and there and and Iran
and they're like this is how it's gonna
be that's what I think happens yeah
there's I don't think it's Gatewood
we're at a point where we can escalate
to a world war three situation do you
think Trump goes to that meeting [ __ ]
up on diet pills was it does he take
what not adderall what does he take what
they accuse I'm taking oh yeah ever
dream no what is it
what is the the the cold medicine that
he had sudafed yeah that's right who
knows a pseudo effort city nephron yeah
pseudo f adrene okay it's it's like a
speed yes yeah yeah and he got the
European [ __ ] which is stronger okay I I
think it's very useful in negotiations
when you come off as a lunatic that's
true because it's like I don't know what
I'm dealing with now I'm scared that is
true about some I wonder if he's being
used in that regard
yeah I need a wrecking ball yeah like
why we got this guy look around the
[ __ ] Kent its kind of get impeached
yeah so we I mean we can't support him
forever let's just let this guy ball
some people up and get get us some more
dirty work done they hey we're real
sorry about that never happened again
yeah people did you just never to see
him taking a hunk photos at the
Holocaust Memorial in Berlin well he's a
hunk so what's the problem no these are
like ugly while he's at these are extra
hunky extra nobody was looking all sexy
at the camera Fish Face and there's some
fish lips yeah it's almost like is that
is that the Holocaust Memorial and it
was the Holocaust need to see that
didn't he get accused of his campaign
was using fake Twitter accounts is that
true they tracked someone or something
yeah look at that okay that that's the
Holocaust Memorial that's from his
husband is this cool husband yep make
that larger I don't think that's hunky I
think people are being nitpicky he's
standing there it's a comet you don't
think looking over your shoulders to
come hither if it's toast
not to me bro I'm a man yeah okay how do
those come-hither that's sad so is he
and so is its husband I think he could
have been the middle of the saying
something like this is insane what does
the caption say what does it say I love
dick setup this guy oh yeah okay alright
and like my friend Brian Morin who's uh
yeah I think now I changed my opinion
Brian Moylan wrote an article four years
ago that apparently is a thing for gay
dudes to do this and put their photos on
Grindr there's an article like why are
gay dudes taking pictures of the
holocaust memorial and putting alright
this is a thing who could look it up
what yeah
why was there a reason he couldn't
figure it out there's something got to
be in the culture maybe it's a
conspiracy theory
dum-dum-dum maybe someone tricked them
into doing it sort of like some sort of
IRA thing in that right agency that does
the things where they like [ __ ] with
people and get people to get behind
certain causes maybe they trick gay guys
anything it's really hot to take
photographs because you know how Russia
feels about gay people they're not there
yeah so maybe they just like got into
the community and they they do by the
way have gay and lesbian pages and lbgtq
page sure yeah I mean this IRA this
internet resource agency has hundreds
and thousands of eight of different fake
accounts that have a massive impact a
massive impact rather as long as they
got good memes I'm like okay so oh oh
you're canceling a turn the on due to
white power side yeah right then maybe
that's what they're doing maybe the
convincing gay guys to give up hither
come look in front of cemeteries and
this isn't the one just the Jewish
Museum cause of photos of gay male yeah
at berlin's holocaust museum so that's a
thing they do look at that one guy with
its feet up yeah that's look at that per
left all the guys doing handstands what
the [ __ ] man yeah how about that gay guy
in the lower left-hand corner in the
track sitting on the top and attracts
you just ready to sprint over some dick
yet this is a thing this was a thing
this was a thing at six o'clock writing
I'll write it right Wow awesomely
outrageous yeah time flew it's fun here
my friend do you have anything to let
anybody know about how to follow you
just michael malice on twitter and an
Instagram and I'm still not verified so
that's [ __ ] you Instagram how many you
have like 12,000 and Joe salaz tried to
help me and didn't do anything
they don't want you in they don't want
me I'm oh you're a bad person with a
piece of [ __ ] but you're not a
psychopath
no just jokes Instagram he's an
guy that's not sure come on you're not a
bad guy I'm not a nice guy we were doing
so well
we had a great Peter I was playing bad
guy you were supposed to be good cop I'm
badder guy I [ __ ] up thank you hey
this is fun man thanks brother
appreciate it
bye everybody
[Music]